I AGAIN AFTERNOON --
LISTS BRING THIS HEARING.
SO ORDER A WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT --
WE WILL STEPS A QUORUM SHORTLY
BUT WILL BEGIN --
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE --
WE WELCOME SENATOR LARA WHO IS
HERE TO PRESENT.
S. B..
FOURTEEN OH TO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
THERE HAS BEEN MANY ATTEMPTS TO
ADDRESS THEM AS CLASSIFICATION
AND EXPLOITATION OF PORT TRUCK
DRIVERS.
BUT TO DATE THESE VULNERABLE
DRIVER STILL LACK THE
APPROPRIATE PROTECTIONS.
BUT LET ME GIVE YOU SOME CONTEXT
FOR WHY S. B. FOURTEEN O. TO IS
NEEDED.
CALIFORNIA'S PORTS AS YOU KNOW
ARE THE POWERHOUSE DRIVING
ARCTIC ECONOMY AND CONNECTING US
THE WORLD.
MORE THAN 40% OF THE U. S.
SHIPPING CONTAINER TRAFFIC FLOW
THROUGH THE PORT OF LA LONG
BEACH AND OAKLAND.
THE ESTIMATED TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND WOMEN AND MEN WHO ALL
THESE CARGO CONTAINERS AWAY FROM
OUR PORTS HAVE SOME OF THE
HARDEST JOBS IN THIS COUNTRY.
THE STATE LABOR COMMISSIONER HAS
WON MORE THAN FORTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN JUDGMENTS FOR MORE
THAN FOUR HUNDRED DRIVERS.
NO HIGHER COURT HAS EVER
OVERTURNED ANY OF THESE AWARDS
APPEAL AND APPEAL.
IT'S SAY THESE JUDGMENTS RARELY
MATERIALIZE FOR WORKERS AND ARE
RARELY MADE WHOLE Y. BECAUSE
COMPANIES REFUSE TO PAY THAT
REFUSE TO PAY GO OUT OF BUSINESS.
AND POP UP UNDER A NEW NAME.
SENATE BILL FORTUNE THE TWO WILL
CLEAN UP OUR PORTRAIT DRIVING
INDUSTRY ONCE AND FOR ALL.
S. B. FORTUNATE TO ORDER THE
DIVISION OF LABOR STANDARDS
ENFORCEMENT TO CREATE A LIST OF
COMPANIES WITH FINAL JUDGMENTS
FOR LABOR VIOLATIONS INCLUDING
WAIT STAFF FAILURE TO PAY TAXES
AND ILLEGAL DEDUCTIONS.
THE COMPANIES ON THIS LIST HAVE
EXHAUSTED BUT STILL REFUSE TO
PAY DRIVERS WHAT THEY ARE
RIGHTFULLY OWED.
AS THE FOURTEENTH TWO WILL
CONTINUE CALIFORNIA WILL ALLOW
CALIFORNIA HOLD RETAIL COMPANIES
AND SHIP SHIPPERS LIABLE WHEN
THEY HIRE TRUCKING COMPANIES ON
THIS LIST.
I WANT TO THANK THE OPPOSITION
FOR RECOGNIZING THE SERIOUSNESS
OF THIS ISSUE AND ENGAGING WHAT
THAT'S CONSTRUCTIVELY ON THIS
BILL.
AS NOTED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS I INTEND TO MAKE
AMENDMENTS IN THE NEXT --
POLICY COMMITTEE BUT ADDRESS THE
OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS REGARDING
ALLOWING FOR TIME FOR A CUSTOMER
TO TERMINATE AN EXISTING
AGREEMENT WITH THE COMPANY ON
THE WEBSITE.
ESTABLISHING A REGULAR FREQUENCY
OF FOR UPDATES OF THE WEBSITE BY
THE DIVISION OF LABOR STANDARDS
ENFORCEMENT.
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER ABOUT.
THANK YOU I SEE YOU HAVE A
NUMBER OF WITNESSES THAT WILL
ALLOW TO TEACH IT WILL ALLOW THE
SAME FOR THE OPPOSITION PURSUING.
A MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
VERY BROAD WITH THE TEAMSTERS
WERE SPONSORS OF THE BILL.
ON THE MEDIA SAY THAT THIS IS.
TERRIBLE PROBLEM. FOR MANY MANY
YEARS AND WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS.
CREATES A LIST.
BOB UNSATISFIED FINAL JUDGMENTS
AND RIGHT NOW THERE'S ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED OF THOSE FROM TWO
HUNDRED DIFFERENT TRUCKING
COMPANIES.
ADDING TO ABOUT FORTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS OWED TO WORKERS
THAT IS FUN PAID --
UNDER THE BILL.
I IF A TRUCKING COMPANY SHOWS UP
ON THE LIST.
A SHIPPER HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SEVER THEIR RELATIONSHIP WITH
THAT TRUCKING COMPANY.
AND ONLY HAS JOINT LIABILITY
UNDER THIS.
IF THEY DON'T SEVER THEIR
RELATIONSHIP.
THE TRUCKING COMPANY AND THE
TRUCKING COMPANY FAILS TO
SATISFY THE JUDGMENT.
AND THE CONTINUE TO VIOLATE THE
LAW.
WHILE THE DRIVER IS HAULING
FREIGHT ON BEHALF OF THAT
SHIPPER SO IT'S ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE. FOR A SHIPPER TO GET
TO JOINT LIABILITY IF THEY
SIMPLY LOOK AT THE LIST
[inaudibe]
AND GO TO ANOTHER TRUCKING
COMPANY AND IT'S EASY FOR
TRUCKING COMPANIES TO GET OFF
THE LIST IF HAVE UNSATISFIED
FINAL JUDGMENTS THEY JUST NEED
TO PAY THEIR WHAT THEY OWE THEIR
WORKERS.
AND THE TAXES THAT THEY OWE TO
THE STATE BOB.
I WANT TO INTRODUCE OR HEY IT
MIGHT WORK OUT.
HE'S ONE OF OUR DRIVERS --
AND HE IS GOING TO TESTIFY IN
SPANISH [inaudible]
AND JESSICA DURHAM FROM LANE IS
GOING TO TRANSLATE FOR HIM.
SO.
IS ALSO ONE OF MY CONSTITUENTS
MANAGEMENT.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT IT HAD DATA.
IT -- WHAT
EFFECT THIS HAS A POOL?
CINEMATICS --
ME NOBODY HOLD HIM MY ORDER THAT.
A YEAR SO YOU I'M TO FAT OF THAT
POLITICAL THEN BAD --
I SAID.
ABOUT ME LUIS INTELLIGENT THEY
GOT YEAH GOSSIPING TIMES
[inaudible]
PORTS AS THE MISCLASSIFIED
DRIVER BY THE COMPANIES.
IT'S A HOLLOW IN THE FED INTO
COMPLAIN YEAH BOOK ON THE
POLITICAL NAY EYES MAHOOD BUT I
ME.
EVEN IF AMELIA EVER DID MANY
DIFFERENT COMPANIES LOOKING FOR
BETTER OPPORTUNITIES FOR MYSELF
AND FOR MY FAMILY.
HE MASON FEEL AWFUL STYLE LOOK
BEHIND.
ALL OF US EXPRESS AIR THEY
CUIDADO INCLUSO COMEY FOR MEDIA
MONOPOLY THAT AND SUPPORT BATTLE.
AND I WAS OFTEN FORCED TO DRIVE
LONG.
HOURS EXTRA HOURS THAT ALSO KEPT
ME SEPARATED AWAY FROM MY FAMILY.
THAT THE JOB MEANT THAT FULLER
HAS COMPLAIN YEAH GET OUT HOW.
IT MICHAEL DELL MUST QUE IT MEAN
WHAT THAT I THOUGHT THEY COULD
MEAN NOT SOON.
AT MAY THINK A MOMENT --
SMITH COME IN AHEAD I'M BEHIND
ARKANSAS UP ABOUT MY AND OVER
THE YEARS I WOULD HAVE --
TO CHANGED YOUNG BIDEN NEW
TRUCKS --
THE TRUCKS BREAKDOWN IN AND
SOMETIMES I COULDN'T AFFORD TO
BUY A NEW TRUCK --
ON THE OUT A LOT OF THEIR THAT
THEY NOT BE THAT.
AND IF THEY ARE ME BECOME YOUNG
AND WHAT ARE SOME MAKOTO. ONE
DAY AROUND CHRISTMAS MY TRACK
THAT THE MOTOR BROKE DOWN.
HE A LITTLE ME SO WATER CAN THEN
YES SEPARATE I'M NOT A PANACEA.
AND ALL THE SAVINGS I HAD HAD TO
GO TO THE TRUCK REPAIRS.
GOOD ON THOUGH --
SA I KNOW.
THE I'M AFRAID THAT A COMPLETE
YEAH.
UP -- I'M
SORRY BUT I THINK THAT I'M GOING
BUT THESE ARE THE REASONS THAT
THAT --
BROUGHT ME TO STAND UP TO THE
COMPANIES AND TO FIGHT FOR
SOMETHING BETTER.
WELL ME SEVEN MONEY SODOMY MEANS
GOT A HOLLOW IT OUT MEANS CAN IS
COMPLETELY OUT OF THAT A WHOLE.
IS IT THE ABOUT THE CPA M.
EMBODIES WHAT IF THAT'S I HAD
STARTED ORGANIZING OF MY
COWORKERS I PARTICIPATED IN
SEVERAL STRIKES.
LET'S AUTHORITIES SAY.
CALL ME SAY --
A CAMBIADO MI VIDA FORTUNATELY
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN MY LIFE
STARTED TO CHANGE THE WAY TO PUT
ON THE AYE POWER HIDING WHEN I
LOOK COMPLAIN YES.
GUEHENNO MIGHT BLESSED FEET KIND
MAYBE ALONG THE LAKE AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK IN ONE OF
THE FEW COMPANIES THAT NO LONGER
MISCLASSIFIED SERVICE VIOLATES
THE LAW.
HE CAN ON THE END UP WITH THEM
YEAH DE FOR MY DON'T LOOK AT THE
LEVEL IT ICONIUM AND GIVE THEM A
CERTAIN INTO FARM ARE --
OUR UNION AND NEGOTIATE A LABOR
CONTRACT WITH THAT THE TEAMSTERS.
I WOULD I GET NOTHING LESS
FINANCED NEARLY PENCIL.
HIT THE MEDIA A CANNELLA SKIMP
ON THIRTY AUGUST NOW I NO LONGER
HAD THE STRATEGIZE SORT OF THE
WAY THEY CARRIED THIRTY YEAR
SPEAK THE COMPANY PROVIDES US
WITH PAID VACATION.
SO I PUT UP WHILE IT IS THIS DO
WE ARE UP FOR YANDLE.
LA LA ME CARE ADULTS AND A LOTTA
[inaudible]
HELLO.
AND IT LIES HAVE A CATHARSIS AT
A LOSS THESE ARE THE REASON I'M
SUPPORTING THE THE THE LOT THAT
WAS INTRODUCED BY SENATOR LARA
SP FOURTEEN UNTIL.
HE HAS BEEN ON THE BECAUSE THIS
TO ME AND A VAN LET YOU TOUCH
HIM TO MOBILE <c.green> THAT MAY NOT</c>
BUT MY CLASSIFICA SYNDICATE
MONTH WITHOUT.
BORDER PUT ONIONS YES IT I MEAN
I'M GONNA LET BE LESS UNIT THAT
I LAY A LACK OF IDEA TO HELP
THAT YOUNG FOR MY STORY YOU CAN
SEE ON AT THE INFAMOUS
CLASSIFICATION.
ON THAT THOUGH IT THE WORKERS.
YOU'RE GIVING BACK TO A
SOMETHING THAT THE COMPANIES
HAVE HAVE TAKEN FROM US FOR THE
NOMINEE TO BE.
A BETTER LIFE WHICH YOU SOME OF
IT AS YOU PEDAL GIVES THIS TIME
AND HOPEFULLY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND I HOPE
THAT YOU SUPPORT US.
CRISIS IN AMERICA --
THE SICK ONE MODE ESTABLISH THE
ROLE THAT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
THURMAN [inaudible]
PRESENT FLORA [inaudible]
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
JONES SAWYER.
KALRA. THREE OF US.
STEINORTH CORMS WE DO HAVE COR
PLEASE CONTINUE.
THINK RICHARD MEMBERS JIM
GROSSET NIELSEN WRITTEN ON
BEHALF OF TOLL GLOBAL.
TOLD GLOBAL IS AN INTERNATIONAL
TRUCKING AND LOGISTICS COMPANY
WHICH HE I IS IN THE PROCESS OF
EXPANDING.
OUR BOTH THROUGH THE UNITED
STATES AND IN CALIFORNIA HOT
WHEN TOLL CAME TO CALIFORNIA I
TO DO BUSINESS THE PORCH IT
IMMEDIATELY RECOGNIZE THAT IT
WAS FACING.
COMPETITION FROM OF COMPANIES
OPERATING ILLEGALLY.
AYE IT TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
TRUCKERS BUT ALSO PUTTING SKI
AYE.
AYE THE PUBLIC AT RISK --
FROM A SAFETY STANDPOINT IT
WANTED TO PARTICIPATE IN A
PROCESS WHEREBY THESE TRUCKERS
OUT WERE BOTH PROTECTED AND THE
COMPANIES THAT WERE.
AYE TRITIUM IS INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS WERE DEALT WITH
STRONGLY IN ORDER TO HAVE NOT
ONLY SAY PORTS BUT TO GIVE US A
CHANCE TO COMPETE FAIRLY.
HOW WE'VE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY
WITH THE TEAMSTERS AND WITH
OTHERS WE THINK THIS BILL ARE IS
THE RIGHT APPROACH WILL ALSO
PROVIDE SOME FEEDBACK THAT I
THINK IT'S HELPED?
ADDRESS SOME OF THE CONCERNS
FROM THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM BUT
WE THINK THIS IS THE BEST
SOLUTION TO A VERY VEXING
PROBLEM THAT AFFECTS THE
INDUSTRY AS MUCH AS IT AFFECTS.
THE WORKER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE OTHER
WITNESSES [inaudible]
SENATOR.
OTHER WITNESSES NO.
THANK YOU OTHERS WISHING TO ADD
ON IN SUPPORT.
MR CHEN MEMBERS CAITLIN VEGA FOR
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
WE ARE CO SPONSORS OF THIS
MEASURE AND I JUST WANT TO THANK
SENATOR LOTT EFFORT TAKING THIS
ONE ON FOR HIS LEADERSHIP AND
FOR THE COURAGE OF ALL OF THE
DRIVERS HAVE SPOKEN OUT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS WISHING AT ON
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN A
COMEDIAN LINDA ESCALANTE WITH
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL AND WERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE WISHING AT
ON IN SUPPORT.
I SEEING NONE --
THIS YEAR ANY OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME FORWARD AND CAN WE
MAKE SPACE FOR THE OPPOSITION.
I'M IN THE MIDDLE.
SO MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
GEORGE MILLER AND HAVE
CALIFORNIA TRUCKING ASSOCIATION
WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE WORK OF
THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF.
IN BERRIEN AT ALL OF DONE --
WE'RE VERY ENCOURAGED BY THAT
THE MOVEMENT AND WE'VE VERY.
MUCH APPRECIATE IT AND WE ARE
NEUTRAL.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER TWEETERS ON
THIS MATTER.
SEEING NONE OF THOSE IN A
POSITION PLEASE PROCEED.
FLAG AFTERNOON MARK CURTIS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE AYE HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE RETAILERS IN THE INDUSTRY.
ARE THE BIGGEST CONCERN WITH THE
BILL AND WE UNDERSTAND --
A SENATOR LARA'S --
OVERALL REASONS FOR THE BILL AND
I'M WE DO APPRECIATE HIS OFFICE
AND SPONSORS WORKING WITH US TO
TRY TO GET TO A POSITION WHERE.
AND WE CAN WORK ON LANGUAGE TO
KIND OF REMEDY SOME OF THESE
CONCERNS BUT THEY OUTLINED HER
OUTSTANDING CONCERNS I'M
CURRENTLY IS THE KNOWLEDGE
REQUIREMENT THEY ARE GOING TO BE.
JOINTLY LIABLE FOR WAGES DAMAGES
AND PENALTIES FOR DRIVERS WHERE
THEY MIGHT NOT HAVE HAD A DIRECT
CONTRACT WITH THIS MOTOR CARRIER
AND THEY JUST DON'T WANT ANY
SURPRISE FACTORS THEY DON'T WANT
SOMEONE TO POTENTIALLY BE PUT ON
THE WEBSITE.
THAT THEN THEY DON'T NOTICES ON
THE WEBSITE OR NO IT'S ON THE
WEBSITE WHERE THEY DID NOT
DIRECT CONTRACT WITH THAT
INDIVIDUAL ON THE WEBSITE
BECAUSE WHILE THERE IS LANGUAGE
IN THERE THAT REQUIRES THE MOTOR
CARRIER TO NOTIFY.
THE CUSTOMER IF THEY ARE ON PUT
ON THE WEBSITE OR IF THEY'RE
GOING TO BE IN HOW THE COURT FOR
THIS KIND OF ISSUE THAT IS NOT A
DEFENSE FOR THAN THE CUSTOMER TO
GET OUT OF LIABILITY OR TWO
REMEDIED ISSUE AND SO THAT'S
WHERE OUR BIGGEST CONCERN IS.
IS THAT REALLY THE ONLY NOTICE
REQUIREMENT IS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT PLACES THESE NAMES ON
A WEBSITE AND THEN DIED AND DO
THAT RETAILER CUSTOMER HAS
NINETY DAYS TO THAN CANCEL THAT
CONTRACT.
AND SO THAT'S WHAT WE'RE ASKING
FOR THE CLARIFYING LANGUAGE JUST
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE EITHER
THEY'RE ASKED TO BE A DIRECT
CONTRACT RELATIONSHIP OR THERE
HAS TO BE SOME SORT OF ACTUAL
KNOWLEDGE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
I'VE BEEN ALL TOMORROW ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION ON THE CHAMBER.
IT WOULD BE VERY WELL --
DID VERY WELL GOOD NICE JAVA
BASICALLY.
STATING WHERE OUR CONCERNS ARE
SO JUST ALIGNED OURSELVES WITH
THOSE COMMENTS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON KIRK BLACKBURN ON
BEHALF OF THE WESTERN STATES
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION AS IT WOULD HAVE A
CHILLING EFFECT ON THE USE OF
SMALL TRUCKING BUSINESSES AT THE
PORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE WISHING TO ADD
ON IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
YOU KNOW SWITCHING AND ON IN
OPPOSITION.
I SEE NONE WILL TURN TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ANY
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
THANK YOU AFTER BRINGING THIS
BILL I'M PROUD TO BE A CO AUTHOR
PRINCE WILL CO AUTHOR ON THE
BILL AND I JUST WANNA MOVE IT.
THE BILL HAS A MOTION AND A
SECOND AND HAS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION I WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN WAS AGAIN ONE OF HER
FIGHT WE ARE TAKING AMENDMENTS.
TO GIVE A NINETY DAY PERIOD FOR
A COMPANY TO EXIT ARE OUT OF THE
CONTRACT.
WE DON'T WANT TO SURPRISE THE
COMPANY AT ALL WHAT WE WANT TO
DO IS UTILIZE THEIR INFLUENCE IN
THE OVERALL CHAIN TO BE ABLE --
TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THIS PERFECT MISS CLASSIFICATION
IS NOT HAPPENING AYE WE'VE TRIED
OTHER WAYS OF GETTING THIS DONE
WE KNOW THAT WE'VE HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL.
BECAUSE THESE COMPANIES THEN
JUST SHUT.
AND THE WORKERS DON'T GET ANY --
OF OF THE MONEY THAT THEY
DESERVE AND AGAIN JUST AS THE
RETAILERS HAVE BEEN --
PART OF ENSURING THAT WE DON'T
USE SWEATSHOPS OR CHILD LABOR
AROUND THE WORLD.
AYE AND THEY TOOK OF A PROACTIVE
STEP TO DO THAT WE WANT THEM TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE ALSO TAKING
CARE OF THE WORKERS HERE IN OUR
COUNTRY.
AYE AND WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
THEM WE'VE HAD GREAT DIALOGUES
OUR INTENT IS NOT TO SURPRISE
THEM AND GIVE THEM.
EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO GET OUT OF
THE CONTRACT AYE IF --
FINAL JUDGMENTS ARE BEING MADE
AGAINST ITS TRUCKING COMPANIES
WHAT THAT I I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE.
YOU SENATOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS YOU PASSED TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE THURMOND AYE
AYE THURMAN AYE FLORA GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE JONES
SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE REDUCE [inaudible]
STEINORTH.
IT BUILDS UP REGULATION THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
I GET THIS SUMMER WELCOME
SENATOR JACKSON WILL BE
PRESENTING TO BILLS TODAY.
S. B. TWELVE EIGHTY FOUR AND S.
B. THIRTEEN HUNDRED WELCOME
SENATOR [inaudible]
CALLING SO.
THIS IS A A BILL TO FIGHT PAY
DISCRIMINATION WITH DATA.
WITH INFORMATION THE BECAUSE
WHEN IT COMES TO PAY EQUITY FOR
WOMEN AND MINORITIES.
WE SIMPLY CAN'T FIX WHAT WE
DON'T KNOW.
AND AS YOU ALL KNOW.
EQUAL PAY.
IS AN ISSUE THAT IS VERY CLOSE
TO MY HEART AND I WOULD SUSPECT
TO THE HEARTS OF EACH WOMAN IN
THIS ROOM AND THEN ALSO.
MEN WHO HAVE SPOUSES AND
PARTNERS AND SISTERS AND MOTHERS
WHO HAVE NOT BEEN PAID FAIRLY.
FOR THE WORK THEY DO BECAUSE OF
THEIR GENDER.
THE SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGE WITH
UNEQUAL PAY IS THAT IT'S SO
OFTEN IS HIDDEN.
NOT CHOSE TO EMPLOYEES BUT OFTEN
TO EMPLOYERS THEMSELVES WELL PAY
INEQUITY CONTINUES MOST
EMPLOYERS I BELIEVE. TO REALLY
NOT INTEND TO SHORT CHANGE THEIR
STAFF.
AND RECOGNIZING THE PAY
DISCRIMINATION IS HARD TO DETECT
AND ADDRESS.
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
ANNOUNCED A PROPOSED REVISION TO
A DEMOGRAPHIC REPORT.
THE LARGE EMPLOYERS HAVE BEEN
SUBMITTING TO IT A TO THE
GOVERNMENT FOR MORE THAN FIFTY
YEARS.
IT'S CALLED THE EMPLOYER
INFORMATION REPORT OR THE E. --
Y..
IT WILL A IT WAS A IT IN --
TWENTY FIFTEEN THE INTENT OF THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION TO INCLUDE
THE REPORTING OF PAY DATA BY
RACE AND GENDER.
INTO THAT REPORT BEGINNING IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUT IN AUGUST
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
PUT A HALT TO THIS NEW RULE
DEALING A BLOW TO THE FIGHT FOR
EQUAL PAY.
S. B. TWELVE EIGHTY FOUR AIMS TO
ENSURE THE CALIFORNIA COLLECTS
THIS IMPORTANT PAY DATA
EMPLOYERS WERE ALREADY POSED A
POISED AND PREPARED TO START
REPORTING.
EVEN IF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
DOES NOT REQUIRED.
MODELED CLOSELY AFTER THE OBAMA
ORDER -- S.
B. TWELVE EIGHTY FOUR WILL
REQUIRE EMPLOYERS WITH A HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES OR MORE. TO SUBMIT A
PAID OUT A REPORT ANNUALLY TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS.
OUTLINING THE COMPENSATION AND
HOURS WORKED OF EMPLOYEES BY
GENDER.
RACE ETHNICITY AND JOB CATEGORY.
NOW THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
WORKED ON THIS PROPOSAL FOR OVER
TWO YEARS WHICH STAKEHOLDERS
FROM ALL THE VARIOUS GROUPS.
SO THIS IS NOT A HURRIED ALL OR
HAPHAZARD PROCESS.
THE GOAL OF THIS MEASURE IS TWO
FOLD ONE TO ENCOURAGE EMPLOYERS
TO ANALYZE THEIR OWN PAY
PRACTICES.
AND ALLOW FOR SELF CORRECTION
PUT A MIRROR IN FRONT OF
YOURSELF AND SEE WHAT.
IS REFLECTED IN THAT MIRROR.
AND VERY FEW EMPLOYERS HAVE DONE
THAT.
BUT WHEN THEY HAVE DONE THAT THE
PRIMARILY VOLUNTARILY.
MOST OF THEM HAVE DISCOVERED
THAT INDEED THERE ARE PAY
INEQUITIES THAT THEY WEREN'T
EVEN AWARE OFF.
AND BECAUSE I BELIEVE MOST
EMPLOYERS DO NOT WANT TO
DISCRIMINATE ON THE BASIS --
PAY A ON THE BASIS OF GENDER
THEY HAVE CORRECTED THIS ISSUE.
THAT WOULD BE THE ULTIMATE
PERFECT GOAL. TO ACHIEVE BY THIS
BILL BUT IT ALSO ALLOWS THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS TOGETHER IMPORTANT
DATA THAT ALLOWS THEM TO SEE
PATTERNS OF WAGE DISPARITIES.
AND IF THEY DIDN'T NOTICE
DEVIATIONS ARE OUT LIARS THEY
WOULD THEN BE ABLE TO
INVESTIGATE FURTHER.
SO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT BASED
UPON SOME OF THE MISINFORMATION
THAT IS OUT THERE TO NOTE WHAT
THIS BILL IS NOT.
THIS BILL IS NOT ABOUT PUBLIC
SHAMING.
AND I HAVE TAKEN AMENDMENTS THAT
ENSURE THAT THIS IS VERY CLEAR.
IT WILL NOT EXPOSE INFORMATION
THAT IS IDENTIFIABLE BY BUSINESS
TO THE PUBLIC NOR WILL IT
EXPOSED EMPLOYEES PRIVATE
FINANCIAL INFORMATION TO THE
PUBLIC.
I'VE TAKEN THE UNUSUAL STEP OF
PROHIBITING DISCLOSURE UNDER THE
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT TO ASSURE
THAT.
THE LIMITATION ON PUBLIC
AVAILABILITY OF THE REPORTS IS
SIMILAR TO WHAT OCCURS AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL WHERE THEY HAVE
HAD NO ISSUES WITH ON TOWARD
DISCLOSURE OF THIS DATA IN THE
FIFTY PLUS YEARS SINCE THE FORM
HAS BEEN REQUIRED.
THIS DATA WILL PROVIDE A BIRDS
EYE VIEW ON PAY DISPARITIES AND
OCCUPATIONAL SEGREGATION BUT
DOES NOT DO SO IN THE GRANULAR
WAY THAT COULD BE USED TO
IDENTIFY SPECIFIC INDIVIDUALS.
THE INFORMATION IS NOT INTENDED
AND CANNOT BE USED TO ENFORCE
THE CALIFORNIA FAIR PAY ACT
BECAUSE THAT ACT A A DOES ALLOW
FORD.
DIFFERENTIALS IN PAY BASED UPON
CERTAIN SPECIFIC LEGITIMATE
CRITERIA SUCH AS SIMPLY A IT
EXPERIENCE EDUCATION AND OTHER
ITEMS THAT WOULD.
POSSIBLY GENERATED DIFFERENTIAL
IMPACT --
AND WE SOMETIMES REFER TO THEM
AS BONA FIDE REASONS FOR PAYING
ONE EMPLOYER MORE THAN ANOTHER
THAT'S NOT ASK FOR A IN THIS
REPORT EMPLOYERS WILL NOT BE
EXPOSED IN THAT MANNER.
THIS BILL RATHER IS A TOOL TO
SHED LIGHT ON TRENDS AND THE BIG
PICTURE.
AND I WILL AND HAVE BEEN
CONSULTING WITH THE OPPOSITION.
I DON'T KNOW THAT WILL NEVER
COME TO A COMPLETE COMMON GROUND
BUT MY SENSE IS THAT THERE ARE
STILL THINGS WE CAN DO. TO
ASSURE THEM AND BE RESPONSIVE TO
THEY MAY HAVE ABOUT WHAT THIS
BILL DOES NOT DO AND I'M MORE
THAN HAPPY TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THEM --
WE HAVE ALSO RECEIVED REQUESTS
FROM FOLKS REPRESENTING THE
TEMPORARY STAFFING UP OR AGENCY
REFERRAL SECTORS TO INCLUDE
EXEMPTIONS FOR THEM AND I AM
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THEM IN A BELIEVE A IT'S
JUST A QUESTION OF SETTLING ON
LANGUAGE OF FOR THAT.
TERM.
RESULT AND I AM CONFIDENT THAT
WE ARE VERY CLOSE TO SOMETHING
EVERYTHING WE CAN LIVE WITH EVEN
THOSE WHO MIGHT NOT LOVE EVERY
ELEMENT OF THIS BUT THE FACT OF
THE MATTER IS.
EQUAL PAY HAS BEEN THE LAW OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR
SEVENTY YEARS.
GET RECENT STUDIES PREDICT WE
WILL NOT FULLY CLOSE THAT WAGE
GAP FOR A HUNDRED AND ONE YEARS
IF WE DO NOT TAKE ACTION. 40% OF
HOUSEHOLDS HAVE WOMEN AS THEIR
SOLE OR PRIMARY BREADWINNERS.
SO THIS ISN'T JUST ABOUT WOMEN
IN FAIRNESS OR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA IT'S ABOUT LIFTING UP
OUR ENTIRE STATE AND OUR ECONOMY.
I HAVE WITH ME TODAY WITNESSES
WHO HAVE.
BUT WORKING HARD ALONGSIDE OF ME
AND MANY OTHERS IN THIS BUILDING
TO ACHIEVE THAT.
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT EQUAL PAY
LEVEL FOR ALL PEOPLE WORKING IN
OUR STATE THAT WE ARE BASED ON
THE MERITS OF OUR WORK AND NOT
OUR GENDER.
AND WITH ME ARE --
JESSICA STANDER SENIOR COUNSEL
FOR WORKPLACE JUSTICE AND PUBLIC
POLICY AT EQUAL WHITE EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES.
AND RICO YOSHIHARA WHO IS THE
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION AND WITH THAT I
WOULD ASK YOUR HONOR.
YOU CENTER --
WILL HAVE YOU PRESENT YOUR FIRST
WITNESS I'D LIKE TO QUICKLY
THOUGH IT KNOWLEDGE TO ADD NEW
MEMBERS OUT TO THE ASSEMBLY
LABOR COMMITTEE RIPLEY'S TO A
PRESENT ASSEMBLY MEMBER REVERSE.
AND TO WHAT MY PRESENT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STEINORTH WELCOME TO OUR
COMMITTEE I EACH WITNESS WILL
HAVE TWO MINUTES EACH.
PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN MURDERS MY NAME IS
JESSICA SENATOR I'M SENIOR
COUNSEL FOR PLEASE JUSTICE AND
PUBLIC POLICY RIGHTS ADVOCATES.
OUT WE ARE PROUD TO CO SPONSOR
S. B. TWELVE EIGHTY FOUR WHICH
TRIGGERED ADDRESS TWO MAJOR
OBSTACLES TO CHIU CLOSING THE
GENDER AND RACIAL WAGE GAPS IN
THE STATE.
OUT ONE IS THE CONCENTRATION OF
WOMEN IN MY BODIES AND
INDUSTRIES AND ONE IS THE
DIFFICULTY OF DETECTING A P.
DISPARITIES MP DISCRIMINATION
EVEN BY EMPLOYERS THEMSELVES.
AS SENATOR JACKSON LAID OUT THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION --
IN THE DURING THE PAST
MINISTRATION A REVISED THE LONG
STANDING E. O. ONE FORM TO TRY
TO ADDRESS THESE PAY DISPARITIES
IN THE DIFFICULTY OF THIS OF OF
DETECTING THEM BY REVISING THEIR
E. O. ONE FORM --
I WOULD JUST ELABORATE A BIT ON
THE PROCESS THAT THE EEOC TOOK A
IN IN IN CHANGING THE FOREMAN
AND PROVIDING THESE REVISIONS --
THEY WENT THROUGH TWO YEARS --
TWO PLUS YEARS OF OF
INVESTIGATING WHAT WOULD BE THE
MOST APPROPRIATE PROCESS TO
COLLECT AFFECTED P. DATA IN A
WAY THAT WILL BE LEAST
BURDENSOME ON EMPLOYERS OTHER
WENT THROUGH TWO ROUNDS OF
NOTICE AND PUBLIC COMMENT.
CONSULTATIONS OF EMPLOYER
REPRESENTATIVES STATISTICIANS AT
HUMAN RESOURCES INFORMATION
SYSTEMS EXPERTS AND THEY
CONDUCTED VERY STUDIES ARE
INDEPENDENT ENTITIES A TO
DETERMINE THE MOST EFFICIENT AND
EFFECTIVE WAY AND THE LEAST
COSTLY WAY FOR EMPLOYERS TO
COLLECT HIS PAY DATA.
AND THEY DETERMINED THAT THIS
PROCESS THAT THEY THAT THEY CAME
UP WITH AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL --
AND THAT PROCESS OF PAIDEIA
COLLECTION WOULD BE THE LEAST UP
BURDEN SOME BUT ALSO THE MOST
EFFECTIVE AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
FORUM HERE IN OUR BILL EYES
MIRRORED ON AS SENATOR JACKSON
EXPLAINED.
THIS REALLY HELPS EMPLOYERS --
DETERMINE WHETHER MAYBE
DISPARITIES IN BUT ALSO WHERE
THERE MAY BE WHAT WE REFER TO AS
OCCUPATIONAL SEGREGATION THAT
THEY MIGHT NOT HAVE BEEN AWARE
OF AND THIS HAS COME ABOUT IN
THE CUP WITH THE COMPANIES HAVE
CHOSEN VOLUNTARILY.
DO THESE KINDS OF ANALYSES LIKE
SALES FORCE DELTA AND SEVERAL
OTHER LARGE COMPANIES THEY FOUND
THAT WITHIN THEM WOMEN AND
MINORITIES ARE OFTEN FUNNELED
INTO THESE LOWER PAID POSITIONS.
SEGREGATION PATTERNS EXIST AND
MAKE CHANGES ON IN THEIR HIRING
AND PROMOTION RETENTION PROP
POLICIES SUCH THAT THEY CAN
BETTER REPRESENT PEOPLE ALL
SPECTRUMS ON THE WAGE SCALE --
AN ADDITION YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD
FROM CENTER JACKSON THE
AFFIRMATIVE ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS
OF THIS WILL HELP OUR STATE
AGENCIES WITH TO USE THEIR VERY
LIMITED RESOURCES IS CRITICAL
I'M HAVING THIS P. DATA AS
YOU'VE HEARD IT WON'T BE
INDIVIDUALLY IDENTIFIABLE.
IT WON'T BE PUBLICLY AVAILABLE
IT WILL HELP OUR STATE
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES USE THE
LIMITED TIME AND RESOURCES THEY
HAVE TO LOOK FOR BROADER
PATTERNS IN INDUSTRIES AND
OCCUPATIONS WHERE THEY MIGHT
THEN DO A DEEPER DIVE TO
DETERMINE IF THERE'S ENFORCEMENT
NECESSARY --
ALTERNATE OVER MY COLLEAGUES
JENNINGS WITH CROWLEY TO TALK A
BIT MORE THE FOR THESE REASONS
WE I DO URGE DRIVE VOTE THANK
YOU.
THINK YOU SHANNON SMITH CALLING
ON BEHALF OF AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
FOR CALIFORNIA --
WE DID A LOT THE LAST FEW YEARS
THANKS TO CHAT CENTER JACKSON
OTHERS.
BUT THIS PROBLEM IS SO
PERSISTENT WE NEED THIS OTHER
TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX.
WEEK THERE THE STATISTIC ABOUT
40% OF HOUSEHOLDS ARE EITHER THE
WOMEN ARE THE PRIMARY OR SOLE
BREADWINNER.
THIS MEANS EIGHTY SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR.
IN LOST WAGES TO CALIFORNIA
WOMEN SO THINK ABOUT HOW MANY
WOMEN ARE WORKING ONE OR MORE
JOBS AND ARE STILL NEEDING A
WHOLE ARRAY OF PUBLIC SERVICES.
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT GETTING A
FAIR WAGE.
WE'RE LOOKING THE STUDY SHOWS
ONLY ABOUT 6212% OF WEIGHT OF
THE WAGE GAP IS DUE TO ACTUAL
OUTRIGHT BIAS OR DISCRIMINATION.
SOME OF THIS IS HIS JOB
SEGREGATION.
SOME OF THIS IS NEGOTIATE WOMEN
TEND NOT TO NEGOTIATE.
AS HEAVILY AS MEN DO ON A EW'S
ACTUALLY COMMITTED TO TRAINING
TEN MILLION WOMEN ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES BY.
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY TWO ON WHICH
NEGOTIATION OR SELLING GOSHI XIN
BUT EVEN WITHOUT THE STUDY SHOW.
WOMEN OR NOT RECEIVED THE SAME
WAY WHEN WE CAN NEGOTIATE FOR
OURSELVES.
AS MEN ARE SO THAT'S NOT WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO TO DO.
A LOT OF THIS IS.
THERE'S JUST THE PERPETUATION OF
THE STATUS QUO CAN I'M I LIKEN
THIS TO STEPPING ON THE SCALE
COULD ONLY GO WE STEP ON THE
SCALE BUT IT'S HELPFUL TO BE
ABLE TO KNOW.
BUDGET TO DO THAT --
ISN'T.
THINK OTHER PEOPLE AGREE ARM IN
ALSO HOW THE CAN HELP PERVASIVE
THIS IS THIS IS ALL WOMEN.
ALL RACES ETHNICITIES
PROFESSIONS.
EVERYTHING FROM FROM YOU KNOW
FROM.
UNSKILLED WORK TO PROFESSIONAL
WOMEN THE LOOKING AT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THE LOOK CAREER OF
A PROFESSIONAL WOMAN THAT SHE
DOES NOT MAKE COMPARED TO MEANT.
EVEN IN.
THE MEDICAL PROFESSION.
FEMALE OBGYN SPEAK LESS THE MAIL
WILL BE CHAINED LANDS FEMALE
NURSES.
MAKE LESS THAN MALE NURSES.
SO WE NEED TO CLEAR THIS UP IN
TO HAPPEN AGAIN OTHER TOOLS ARE
TOOLBOX KNOWN WE THIS IS A VITAL
TOOL TO HELP EMPLOYERS.
SEE FOR THEMSELVES MAKE A CHANGE
THANK YOU.
GIVE THIS.
ONE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
REYES MARK AREA SHE HIGH WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION ALSO WORKED WITH.
AND THE AUTHOR AND THEY CO
SPONSORS ON A LOT OF THE THE
PAST --
REFORMS IN THE PAST FEW YEARS TO
CHECK THEIR EQUAL PAY LAWS WE
THINK THIS IS THE APPROPRIATE
NEXT STEP I'M AS MY COLLEAGUE
POINTED OUT THIS THIS ISN'T JUST
ABOUT PAY DISCRIMINATES
DISCRIMINATION IS ABOUT
OCCUPATIONAL SEGREGATION AS WELL.
WE THINK THAT THIS ALLOWS
GREATER ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THOSE
EMPLOYERS TO DO THOSE PAY AUDITS
TO TAKE A DEEPER DIVE AND LOOK
AT THEIR PAY DATA TO ENSURE THAT.
NOT JUST THAT THEY'RE PAYING
THEIR WORKERS FAIRLY BUT THE
ALSO THE HIRING PRACTICE IN THE
PROMOTION PRACTICES ARE FAIR AND
EQUITABLE AS WELL.
SO STRONG SHOWING THEIR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO
ADD ON IN SUPPORT.
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION HERE
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
LIKELY ON THE HALF DAYS SO YOUR
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT MAKE YOU.
JOSH WILL GO WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GLORIA CHUNK FROM LEGAL AID AT
WORK IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MARK SCHACHT OF CRLA FOUNDATION
OF SPORT.
THEY KEEP IT WOULD ALSO SHOULD
ADD ON IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IF THERE'S
OPPOSITION WOULD YOU PLEASE COME
FORWARD
.
PLEASE PROCEED HELLO GOOD
AFTERNOON MARK CURTIS THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND AND YES WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH AUTHOR AND WE APPRECIATE
AND THE EFFORTS IN ORDER TO
RESOLVE SOME OF THE MORE
TECHNICAL ISSUES WITH THE BILL.
AND IT JUST A FEW THINGS TO
CLARIFY --
FIRST FROM OUR UNDERSTANDING THE
EOC -- THE
FORM WAS NOT COMPLETELY DONE AT
THE TIME AND THAT IT WAS
SUSPENDED AT LEAST THE COMMENT
PERIOD AND THE CONSIDERATIONS
WERE STILL BEING OPEN AND IT WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE.
AMENDED TO ACTUALLY INCLUDE THAT
ALL OF THE VERY TECHNICAL ISSUES
REGARDING THE W. TWO BOX THAT
WAS USED FOR THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE W. TO BOX
ONE THE SNAPSHOT PERIOD WOULD BE
FROM.
OCTOBER TO DECEMBER RATHER THAN
AS THE TIMBRE AND SO THOSE ARE
KIND OF TECHNICAL ISSUES THAT
WERE STILL TAKING UP WITH THE
BILL AND WE THIS IS A JOB KILLER
FOR THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WE ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL.
AND BECAUSE WHILE THE AUTHOR'S
INTENT IS NOT THE PUBLIC SHAMING
WE ARE VERY CONCERNED THAT THIS
STILL WILL BE TO PUBLIC SHAMING
BECAUSE IT SAYS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
HOUSING SHALL NOT MAKE FISH IT
IT WOULD BE UNLAWFUL FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
HOUSING TO MAKE.
THIS INFORMATION PUBLIC ARE I
MEAN YES TO MAKE IT AND BAD
PUBLIC.
PRIOR TO THE INSTITUTION OF
LITIGATION UNDER EITHER THE FAIR
PAY ACT OR THE GOVERNMENT CODE
SO ONCE A LITIGATION IS AND
COMMENCE THEN THE INFORMATION
COULD BE TURNED OVER BY THE
DEPARTMENT.
AND THAT IS A STRONG CONCERN FOR
US AND ADDITIONALLY OVERALL ARE
CONCERNED WITH THE ISSUE IS THAT
IT AGAIN LIKE THAT --
AUTHOR STATED THAT THIS DOES NOT
TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION THE BONA
FIDE FACTORS SO WHILE IT'S
TAKING ITS LOOKING AT AGGREGATE
DATA FROM PLAYERS THERE'S NO
EMPLOYER THAT'S NOT GOING TO
HAVE A WAGE DISPARITY ON THESE
REPORTS.
BUT WHETHER OR NOT THAT'S
UNLAWFUL WAGE DISPARITY IS THE
CONCERN AND THEN ALL THE SUDDEN
THIS COMPANY IS NOW SEEN AS
SOMEONE WHO HAS UNLAWFUL WAGE
DISPARITY WHEN NOT MIGHT NOT BE
THE CASE THAT THE SITUATION
BECAUSE FOR EXAMPLE IN THIS
BUILDING.
GIVE A STAFFERS WORK FREE FOR
TWO WEEKS VERSUS STAFFER WHO'S
WORKED THREE FOR THIRTY YEARS
THOSE EFFORTS ARE GONNA BE MOST
LIKELY AND AT THE SAME JOB TITLE
BUT YOU'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE YOU
HAVE.
ESSENTIALLY A SOME IN SOME
ABILITY TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION WHILE THEY'RE BEING
PAID SEPARATELY YOU'D HAVE TO
COMPARE THAT INDIVIDUAL TO EVERY
OTHER STAFFER AND THEN YOU HAVE
TO COMPARE IT THEM TO EACH OTHER.
SO IT'S JUST NOT A FEASIBLE WAY
FOR THE EMPLOYER TO DO THAT
UNDER THIS ITEM BILL AND SO
THAT'S OUR BIGGEST CONCERN WOULD
BE THAT THE PUBLIC SHAMING
ASPECT IN THE FACT THAT IT'S NOT
REALLY LOOKING AT UNLAWFUL
BEHAVIOR [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER AND MISTER CHRIS MCKAY
LIAM BE HALF A CUP TEA IN THEI
AMBULANCE ASSOCIATION RIGHT TO
TWO ISSUES IN PARTICULAR BE
QUICK --
FIRST OF ALL WE ARE VERY
THANKFUL --
FOR A CENTER JACKSON TO TAKE
SUBDIVISION A J. ARE REMAINING
CONCERN IS IN SUBDIVISION I AND
I'M SORRY DIDN'T PRINT OUT THE
PAGE AND LINE ITEM BUT IN
SUBDIVISION THE LANGUAGE THAT
MISS CURTIS REFERENCED AND IN
PARTICULAR THE CLAUSE THE PRIOR
TO INSTITUTION.
OF ANY PROCEEDING.
AND SO WE FEEL LIKE THERE'S SOME
PARTIAL PROTECTION OF THE
INFORMATION NOT BE MADE PUBLIC.
BUT NOT FULLY SO WE FROM CAN I
DO SOMETHING I IN SUBDIVISION I
THE OTHER ISSUE THAT WE RAISED
WITH --
CENTER WITH THE AUTHOR IS --
I REQUEST.
TO ESSENTIALLY PRECLUDE ANY
POTENTIAL LIABILITY.
UNDER THESE PROVISIONS --
THAT WOULD BE FOUND FOR
VIOLATION OF THIS SECTION SO WE
HAD PROPOSED SOME LANGUAGE OF
ESSENTIALLY SAYING COMPLIANCE
WITH THIS SECTION --
SHALL NOT RESULT IN ANY CIVIL
LIABILITY OR GOVERNMENTAL ACTION
PURSUANT TO THE EPA OR BUFFY HA --
AT THIS POINT YOU KNOW THE
AUTHOR IS REJECTED THAT --
SUGGESTED --
MEANT A REQUESTED AMENDMENT AND
FOR THOSE REASONS WE CAN SIT
CONTINUE TO HAVE THOSE
LITIGATION CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE
POSED SINCE THE FIRST COMMITTEE
HEARING IN THE SENATE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HIGH --
MICROBES IN HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA IT'S IN THE
AMERICAN STAFFING ASSOCIATION
AND SO WE WE REPRESENT THE
TEMPER STAFFING INDUSTRY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
I'M PUSHING THE AUTHORS A
COMMITMENT ON THE ON ON SOME
LANGUAGE TO DEAL WITH THAT THE
STAFFING ISSUE INTEREST JUST
JUST. FOR BACKGROUND PURPOSES SO
YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE IS THAT ON THAT --
EEL ONE REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
I'M GOING BACK.
I KNOW I'VE BEEN TOLD DOZENS
MAYBE YOU KNOW FORTY YEARS OR
HOWEVER LONG I DON'T KNOW HOW
LONG IT'S BEEN EXISTENCE BUT
THERE'S A THERE'S A WHOLE LIST
OF POSSIBLE EMPLOYERS ARE TYPES
EMPLOYERS ARE EXCLUDED FROM
REPORTING.
CURRENTLY THAT THE CURRENT TRACK
TYPE THE DATA.
AND AND RELEASE ALL THE MEN THAT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR IS JUST TO SAY
IF YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE NOT
REQUIRED TO REPORT UNDER THE
FEDERAL E. L.. ONE REPORTING
REQUIREMENT JUST.
MAINTAIN THAT FOR CALIFORNIA FOR
THAT FOR THE NEW REQUIREMENT ON
THE PAID DATA AND SO IT'S
OTHERWISE YOU'D BE CAPTURING
PEOPLE REALLY TWICE PEOPLE WHO
HAVEN'T BEEN REPORTING.
ANYTHING.
BECAUSE ARE ARE EXCLUDED AND
THEN ADDING THE PAYDAY THAT
THING ON TOP OF A AND AND
THERE'S RATIONALE FOR THAT AND
AND WE'VE EXPLAINED AT THE
OFFICE STAFF AND EXPLAIN IT HERE
BUT I THINK YOU'RE IN A HURRY SO
[inaudible]
THE KEYBOARD.
THANK YOU WE WILL HEAR ALL
ARGUMENTS DESPITE TIME --
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO ADD ON IN
OPPOSITION.
I BEHALF OF THE FAMILY BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
KATIE HANSON OF THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION FOR THE
REASONS STATED WERE OPPOSED MAKE
YOU.
THE CALL RICE CALVARY
MANUFACTURES IN TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION ALSO POST MAKE YOU.
AND BRIAN LITTLE OF CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU FOR THE REASONS
OUTLINED BY MY COLLEAGUE FROM
THE CHAMBER ALSO OPPOSED THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS WISHING THAT ON
IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE --
TRYING TO THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER [inaudible]
AND IT KIND OF AMAZED BY THE
OPPOSITION'S ARGUMENTS BECAUSE
HAVING HAD A SIMILAR BILL LAST
YEAR IT'S YOU'RE TAKING A
DIFFERENT APPROACH AND YET.
WERE STILL OPPOSED --
I VERY MUCH THINK THE COMPANY
SHOULD BE SHAMED AND THAT'S WHY
I THINK THIS DOESN'T GO FAR
ENOUGH --
IT'S CLEAR.
IT'S CLEAR THAT WHEN WE ALLOW
THE MARKET TO WORK PUBLICLY AND
OPENLY FORT.
THE COMPANIES HAVE TO REPORT IF
THEY HAD REPORT PUBLICLY THAT
THEY'D BE MORE LIKELY TO EXAMINE
THEIR OWN DATA AND DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT.
BUT I'M OKAY WITH THIS HALF STEP.
IN THAT'S REALLY WHAT I CONSIDER
IT SO -- I I
HOPE WE CAN WORK ON THIS IN THE
FUTURE TO BRING IT TO A FULL
SHAME MEAN --
THAT COMPANIES DESERVE HILL DO
NOT --
FOLLOW PAY EQUITY RULES AND WHO
ARE NOT PROACTIVELY MOVING
FORWARD TO CHANGE A SITUATION
WITH THEIR OWN THEIR OWN
WORKFORCE.
EXAMPLE OF OF COURSE TO PEOPLE
WHO WORK FOR VERY DIFFERENT
PERIODS OF TIME COULD BE NOTED
IN ANY PAPERWORK OR ANYTHING
THAT THEY MOVE FORWARD AND YOU.
WOULD NEVER FACED A LAWSUIT
BASED ON SOMEBODY WHO HAS THE
SAME JOB TITLE BUT WAS THERE FOR
TWO YEARS VERSES EIGHTEEN YEARS --
WE KNOW WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO GET
OUT WE ALL DO SO I I APPRECIATE
LIKE I SAID WHAT I THINK IS A
HALF STAFF --
AYE I AM PROUD TO MOVE THIS BILL
I THINK I'M A CO AUTHOR ON IT
BUT I THINK YOU FOR WORK FOR
KEEPING DOING WORK ON THIS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU CENTER FOR BRING THIS BILL
FORWARD I THINK IT.
AB THIS IMPORTANT A STEP BY.
JOIN WITH MY COLLEAGUES ARE NO
THE THING PRINCIPLE KALRA JOIN
HONOR.
BILL LAST YEAR --
WHICH I THINK WAS A FOR THAT YOU
THINK.
WE A STEP.
IN A VERY POSITIVE EXCEPT THINK
IT IS IMPORTANT --
FOR COMPANIES TO BE ABLE.
TO LOOK AT THE MIRROR AND SEE
WHERE THEY ARE AND TO DO IT
INTENTIONALLY.
AND I KNOW THAT THAT LAST YEAR
THE CRITICISM WAS THAT COULD BE
PUT TO SHAME BECAUSE A PUBLIC
SCHOOL CLOSURE NOW ITS.
POTENTIAL EXPOSURE COULD CAUSE
SHAMING AND IN THE END OF THE
DAY -- I
KNOW THAT YOUR INTENTION JUST
SAYS THE INTENTION [inaudible]
WELL.
YOU'RE IN TOUCH IS NOT
SPECIFICALLY TO SHAME ANYONE I I
KNOW THAT'S BECAUSE YES I CAN GO
BACK -- TO
BUT BUT THE REALITY IS THIS LOOK
THAT THIS HAS BEEN A PROBLEM FOR
DECADES.
I'M AND IT CAN BE PAINFUL TIES
REST LOOK AT OURSELVES WHETHER
ACCOMPANIES OTHER INDIVIDUALS
SOCIETY A LEGISLATURE --
IT'S NOT EASY THING TO DO.
THERE'S NO DOUBT ABOUT IT BUT
THE REALITY IS THAT --
THE MARKET HAS ADJUSTED ON ITS
OWN THE STATUS QUO HASN'T WORKED --
MAN AND YOU KNOW I THINK WE'LL
TIMES UP AS IT APPLIES TO
CERTAINLY MAKING SURE.
THAT WE ARE DOING MORE THAN WE
HAVE DONE IT STARTS WITH DATA
SOURCE OF INFORMATION THE STARS
THE COMPANIES BE ABLE TO LOOK AT
THAT INFORMATION.
AS SOME COMPANIES HAVE STARTED
TO DO -- AND
SAY OKAY WHAT ARE WE DOING LOOK
WE BE DOING BETTER.
AYE BECAUSE EVEN FOR ALL THESE
FACTORS THAT ARE LISTED THAT MAY
NOT.
BE ME NOT ACCOUNT FOR THE
REALITY IS WE KNOW THAT EVEN IF
YOU COUNT FOR EVERYTHING THEY'RE
STILL MAJOR DISPARITY.
OF WITH WOMEN AND MEN IN TERMS
OF PAY.
AND WE KNOW THAT'S THE CASE THEN
WE WOULD BE RESPONSIBLE WE
DIDN'T TRY DO SOMETHING SERIOUS
ABOUT IT --
I THINK THAT EMPLOYERS ARE
SERIOUS ABOUT SOLVING THIS
PROBLEM WILL LIKE TO SEE THAT
DATA --
THEY'VE HOPEFULLY HAVE ALREADY
DONE IT ON THEIR OWN.
ANALYSIS BUT THE CASE IT MAY BE
THAT MANY HAVE AN AND SO THIS
FORCES THE ISSUE --
AND REQUIRES UNDERTAKE ó A
GOOD HARD LOOK AT THEIR OWN
PRACTICES AND WHAT THEY CAN DO
BETTER AND THAT IT'S IT'S NOT A
MATTER OF OF A RELEASE ON A
MATTER OF SAYING WELL THIS IS A
GOOD COMPANY VERSUS BACK UNDER
THE REALITIES ARE SOCIETIES AT
THIS PROBLEM.
IT'S A SYSTEMIC ISSUE THE WAY
YOU GET RID OF SYSTEMIC ISSUES
IS TAKING A SYSTEMIC LOOK A DEEP
DIVE INTO THE NUMBERS A DEEP
DIVE INTO THE DATA.
FROM THAT YOU COULD ACTUALLY
HAVE SOLUTIONS THAT THEN YOU CAN
MEASURE OVER TIME TO SEE IF
YOU'RE ACTUALLY MAKING PROGRESS
ON THAT SYSTEMIC ISSUE.
BUT WE'RE NOT EVEN WILLING TO
LOOK AT THE NUMBERS WERE NOT
WILLING TO LOOK AT OURSELVES
THEN BRING KNOWLEDGE OF THE
SYSTEM IS JUST FINE AND I CAN
NOT A KNOWLEDGE THAT.
THANK YOU.
HE SAID MEMBER KALRA MISTER VICE
CHAIR.
HELLO SENATOR I APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS AND AND I JUST
WANT TO MAKE ONE COMMENT IN
HINDA.
IS FAST IN THAT WE'RE GOING
AFTER FOR BUSINESSES PRIVATE
BUSINESSES.
WHEN WE HAVE?
THE WAGE ISSUE WITHIN THE STONE
BUILDING [inaudible]
BETWEEN PARTIES.
MATTER WOULD DEPEND ON WHAT
PARTY THAT YOU FILL IT WITH.
DICTATE YOUR PAY.
AND SO I WOULD ENCOURAGE US IF
THIS IS GOING TO BE SOMETHING
THAT WE INFLICT ON PRIVATE
BUSINESSES AND MAKE AYE AND I
CAN'T SUPPORT IS.
TO I THINK WE TAKE ONCE AGAIN AN
INTERNAL LOOK AT THIS BUILDING.
BECAUSE WE HAVE THE SAME ISSUES
RIGHT HERE.
ANY OTHER DISCUSSION OR
QUESTIONS COMMENTS --
THE BILL HAS A MOTION IS OUR
SECOND.
THOSE BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED --
I'M SENATOR WOULD LIKE CLOSE
THANK YOU YES UP I DON'T
CONSIDER THIS AN INFLICTION --
WHETHER WE HAVE PROBLEMS IN THIS
BILL I DON'T THINK ANY OF US
DISAGREE WITH THAT HOW WE'RE
TRYING TO FIX SOME OF THEM --
WE SHOULD BE FIXING.
OF ALL OF THEM A GOVERNMENT JOBS
THOUGH OR PUBLIC --
AND THE INFORMATION --
IS AVAILABLE THE IT NOT THE CASE
IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR AND SO --
I I I THINK THERE'S A VERY
IMPORTANT DISTINCTION TO TO BE
DRAWN.
A IT IS FAR SAID IS CONCERNED --
AND I WANT --
TO AT RESPOND IF I MAY TO IT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER A GONZALEZ
FLETCHER --
WHEN I HEAR YOU TALKING I THINK
TO MYSELF NO GOOD DEED GOES
UNPUNISHED?
BECAUSE LAST YEAR WHERE WE HEARD
YOUR BILL AND I SUPPORTED IT --
IT WAS PRETTY OUT THERE AND AND
FOR ALL THE REASONS YOU'VE
MENTIONED TODAY I THINK THAT
MAKES SENSE.
BUT I UNDERSTOOD THAT THAT THAT
THERE MIGHT BE A WAY TO GET. TO
THE SAME RESULT WITHOUT DOING
QUITE IS DRAMATICALLY AND THAT'S
THE BILL I BROUGHT THIS YEAR AND
IT'S STILL A JOB KILLER BILL WHY
WELL BECAUSE HE'S COMPANIES
DON'T WANT.
TO MAKE THIS INFORMATION
AVAILABLE.
IT'S LIKE WHAT EVERYBODY SAYS
THEY DON'T WANNA CHECK THEY
DON'T THEY DON'T WANT THIS
DISCRIMINATION BUT THEY'RE NOT
PREPARED TO DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
AND WE KNOW THAT WHEN YOU DON'T
DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT NOTHING
CHANGES.
SO THIS IS A BILL.
THAT THAT LOOKS AT HER FROM THE
NOT THE GRANULAR LEVEL THE
NOTION OF THE ARGUMENTS THAT I
KEEP HEARING FROM THE CHAMBER
KEY PRE READING MY BILL AND SAY
HOW.
CAN YOU POSSIBLY INTERPRETED TO
SAY WE'RE GONNA OUT YOU.
HOW CAN YOU INTERPRET IT TO SAY
THAT THIS ISN'T --
THAT THAT THIS IS UNFAIR BECAUSE
IT'S A AGAIN WHEN WE HAVE A PAY
DISPARITIES IT'S GOING TO LUMP
EVERYBODY TOGETHER IT DOES NOT.
IT PUTS THEM INTO CATEGORIES.
NOT INDIVIDUALS BUT CATEGORIES
AND IF THERE IS AS WE KEEP
TALKING ABOUT OCCUPATIONAL
SEGREGATION WHICH WE ALL KNOW
EXISTS IF FORCES COMPANIES TO
LOOK IN THE MIRROR.
AND TO SEE THAT OCCUPATIONAL
SEGREGATION AND TO BE GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CORRECT IT.
THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS.
THEIR ROLE IS TO OUR HELP
IDENTIFY AND TO CORRECT AND TWO
WOULD GIVE INCENTIVES TO CORRECT.
THE THE CHAMBERS ALWAYS WORRIED
ABOUT LITIGATION NO YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO GET SUED IF YOU'RE NOT.
DOING SOMETHING WRONG AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS ROLE HERE IS TO HELP
THESE COMPANIES WHEN THEY'VE
LOOKED IN THE MIRROR AND THEY
SEE THAT THEY ARE.
A THEY HAVE OCCUPATIONAL.
SEGREGATION TO CORRECT IT TO
ASSIST THEM IN CORRECTING IT AND
IF THEY DON'T THAT'S WHEN THE
HAMMER COMES DOWN.
I I CAN'T THINK OF IMPRINT
JOURNAL WAY TO DO THIS.
WE HAVE TO STOP ASKING PRETTY
PLEASE BECAUSE PRETTY PLEASE
HASN'T GOTTEN US A DARN THING
FOR GENERATIONS AND THAT'S LEFT
WOMEN AND FAMILIES WHO ARE
LEAVING SO MUCH MONEY ON THE
TABLE.
AND ARE BEING DENIGRATED FOR
THEIR HARD WORK AND NOT ABLE TO
FEED THEIR FAMILIES THIS IS AN
ECONOMIC ISSUE AND A FAIRNESS
ISSUE.
AND BUSINESSES HAVE GOT TO STEP
FAR AS I CAN SEE AND I'M MORE
THAN HAPPY TO CONTINUE WORKING.
OUT WITH THE CHAMBER AND ANYONE
ELSE AND WE ACTUALLY HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT SOME OF THE
LANGUAGE SO THAT THERE'S NO.
THERE'S NO LEGITIMATE CONCERN
THAT WE'RE JUST LOOKING FOR WAYS
TO EMBARRASSED COMPANIES --
WHICH IS LOOKING FOR WAYS TO
LITIGATE WE'RE GIVING GIVING
PEOPLE AN OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK
[inaudible] TO CORRECT. TO MOVE
ON AND IF WHEN THEY LOOK THEY
DON'T CORRECT THAT'S WHEN THE
HAMMER FALLS AND THAT'S AS IT
SHOULD BE IF I'M NOT MISTAKEN
THAT'S THE WAY.
OUR SYSTEM OF JUSTICE OPERATES
EARLY SHOULD OPERATE WERE GIVING
EVERYBODY A CHANCE. TO COMPLY TO
MOVE THE BALL FORWARD TO PAY
PEOPLE FAIRLY TO PAY THEM
EQUITABLY THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL
DOES UP PROVIDES THAT DATA SO
THAT WE CAN LOOK IN THE MIRROR
AND CORRECT THOSE MISTAKES.
THERE'S NO SHAMING THERE IS NO
FAULT THERE IS JUST LET'S FIX
THE PROBLEM ONCE AND FOR ALL AND
WITH THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE.
THANK YOU SENATOR THIS BILL HAS
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE THURMAN AYE
THURMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA NO GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE JONES
SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE KALRA.
KALRA I BEAT US.
STEINORTH STEINORTH NO.
BUT THAT BILLS OUT
CONGRATULATIONS AND THANK YOU
THINK CLUTCHING ONTO S. B..
THIRTEEN HUNDRED YES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
UP MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
IN CONTINUING TO TRY TO MAKE
SURE THAT ALL THE PROTESTATIONS
THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM.
BOTH WITHIN THIS BUILDING AND IN
THE PRIVATE SECTOR IN.
THE HALLS OF POWER THROUGHOUT.
AMERICA.
THAT WE START --
ADDRESSING THE PROBLEM OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND PREVENTED.
AND MAKE PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE AND
COMPANIES ACCOUNTABLE AND
GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTABLE WHEN WE
DO NOT DO SO.
OVER THE PAST YEAR AS WE ALL ARE
FAIRLY WELL AWARE AS PART OF THE
ME TO MOVEMENT WE'VE HEARD
HUNDREDS IF NOT THOUSANDS OF
BRAVE WOMEN IN MANY MEN AS WELL.
COME FORWARD.
TO SUPPOSE THE PREVALENCE OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT IN WORKPLACES
IN INDUSTRIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
WE'VE SEEN PERPETRATORS FINALLY
BEING HELD ACCOUNTABLE AFTER
DECADES OF ABUSE AND HARASSMENT.
WE'VE SEEN HOW DEVASTATING
SEXUAL HARASSMENT IS TO VICTIMS
TO THEIR CAREERS AND TO THEIR
EMOTIONAL WELL BEING AND WE'VE
ALSO LEARNED HOW CHALLENGING IT
IS TO PREVENT.
AND STOP THIS BEHAVIOR BECAUSE
SEXUAL HARASSMENT IS ABOUT
[inaudible]
NO BETTER.
IT'S ABOUT ENSURING THAT OUR
LAWS OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM AND OUR
WORKPLACE CULTURES ARE WORKING
TO ENSURE THAT WOMEN TRULY HAVE
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY IN THE
WORKPLACE.
WE DO TRUST AS WELL THAT OUR
WORK AS MEN DO WE ARE TRUST A
SMART WE ARE JUST AS CAPABLE WE
IS OUR TRUST US HARD WORKING AND
WE ARE JUSTICE THOSE SERVING.
OF THE KIND OF RESPECT AND
DIGNITY A THAT THOUGH WE ARE
ENTITLED TO THAT ALL PEOPLE ARE
ENTITLED TO IN THE WORKPLACE AND
ELSEWHERE SO THIS IS INDEED A
WORKPLACE CIVIL RIGHTS ISSUE.
NOW BACK IN THE EARLY SPRING I
HELP TO HEARINGS AS THE CHAIR OF
THE SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
AND CHAIR OF THE SENATE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON WOMEN WORKING
FAMILIES.
ABOUT WHAT WE COULD TO DO
ADDRESS SEXUAL HARASSMENT IN
REAL AN ENDURING WAYS IT BECAME
SINGLE MAGIC BULLET TO THIS
PROBLEM.
THERE ARE A VARIETY OF CHANGES
THAT NEED TO BE MADE AND MADE
NOW.
SO THIS BILL RESPONSE TO THAT
CHALLENGE WITH A COMPREHENSIVE
SET OF CHANGES TO THE FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING ACT.
IN BROAD STROKES THOSE REFORMS
MAY BE CHARACTERIZED AS CLOSING
LOOPHOLES IN EXISTING HARASSMENT
LAW STRENGTHENING SEXUAL
HARASSMENT PREVENTION TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS.
AND CRACKING DOWN ON THE USE OF
CONTRACTUAL PROVISIONS WHICH
PREVENT VICTIMS FROM SPEAKING
OUT AND SHIELD SENIOR OF
SHIELDING SERIAL HARASSERS
AGAINST ACCOUNTABILITY.
SO THE KEY HIGHLIGHTS TO THE
BILL ARE.
ONE THIS MEASURE PROVIDES
GUIDANCE TO THE COURTS ON THE
SEVERE AND PERVASIVE LEGAL
STANDARD AND I WILL SAY I WILL
ACKNOWLEDGE THIS IS A HIGH
STANDARD.
BUT IT WAS CLEAR FROM BOTH THE
PLAINTIFF AND DEFENSE SIDE THAT
WITH SOME TWEAKING THIS STANDARD
DOES WORK AND IS WORKABLE
[inaudible]
AND SO
WHAT WE CASUALLY MIGHT LABEL
SEXUAL HARASSMENT IN EVERYDAY
LIFE IS ACTUALLY FAR DIFFERENT
THAN THE NARROW IMPRECISE LEGAL
DEFINITION OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT?
BUT ACCORDING TO THAT LEGAL
STANDARD THE CONDUCT MUST BE
UNWELCOME IT MUST BE
DISCRIMINATORY AND IT MUST MEET
THE LEVEL OF BECOMING SEVERE OR
PERVASIVE WHICH IS A HIGH BAR.
AND FRANKLY HAS TOO OFTEN BECOE
A WAY OF EXCUSING OUTRAGEOUS
BEHAVIOR INSTEAD OF A WAY TO
LIFT UP VICTIMS AND HOLD
PERPETRATORS ACCOUNTABLE.
SO WE SIT WE PRESERVE THAT
STANDARD FOR WHAT CONSTITUTES
HARASSMENT BUT WE PROVIDE KEY
GUIDANCE TO THE COURTS.
ENCOURAGING THEM TO APPLY THE
LAW IN A WAY THAT FOCUSES ON
WORKPLACE FAIRNESS FIRST AND
FOREMOST. TO THIS IN THE BILL
INCENTIVIZE IS EMPLOYERS TO
INTERVENE EARLY. TO PREVENT
INAPPROPRIATE BEHAVIOR FROM
ESCALATING TO THAT SEVERE AND
PERVASIVE STANDARD WHICH WOULD
THEN SUBJECT THEM TO LITIGATION
UNDER CURRENT LAW WHEN PEOPLE
MOSTLY THOUGH NOT EXCLUSIVELY
WOMEN ARE DEALING WITH
INAPPROPRIATE BEHAVIOR AT WORK.
TOO OFTEN THEIR ONLY REAL CHOICE
IS TO SUCK IT UP [inaudible]
ORDER QUIT.
AND WE KNOW IN TODAY'S WORLD HOW
DIFFICULT THAT IS WITH THE THE
THE FACT THAT OF WOMEN ARE IN
THE WORKPLACE TO SUPPORT THEIR
FAMILIES TO KEEP A ROOF OVER
THEIR HEADS TO FEED THEMSELVES
AND THEIR FAMILIES TO KEEP THEM
CLOSE TO BE ABLE.
TO PROVIDE THEM WITH THE BASIC
NECESSITIES OF LIFE AND THIS
REALLY DOESN'T THAT IT ISN'T A A
REAL CHOICE.
IN MANY INSTANCES.
SO THIS BILL.
OF WILL --
TELL EMPLOYERS A OR SAY THAT IN
EMPLOYERS LEGAL DUTY TO TAKE
ACTION BEGINS THE MOMENT THEY
KNOW.
OF UNWELCOME INAPPROPRIATE
BEHAVIOR NOT JUST WHEN THAT
BEHAVIOR METASTASIZE IS INTO THE
KIND OF SEVERE PERVASIVE
MISCONDUCT THE COURTS CALL
HARASSMENT. THREE THIS BILL
STRENGTHENED SEXUAL HARASSMENT
PREVENTION TRAINING REQUIREMENTS
I'VE HEARD FROM A NUMBER OF
PEOPLE AND FRANKLY FROM THIS
BUILDING IS WELL KNOW THAT ARE
SET SEXUAL HARASSMENT TRAINING
PROGRAMS.
ARE NOT ADEQUATE.
AND THAT IS TO SAY THE LEAST.
THIS MEASURE WILL REQUIRE
TRAINING FOR ALL WORKERS NOT
CHIU SUPERVISORS BECAUSE ALL
WORKERS CAN BE THE VICTIMS OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
ANNEKE ALL ALSO CALLS FOR THE
INCLUSION OF INNOVATIVE
BYSTANDER INTERVENTION TRAINING
TECHNIQUES TO DE ESCALATE AND
DISTRACT WHICH NOT ONLY DISRUPT
THAT INAPPROPRIATE BEHAVIOR BUT
ALSO CREATE A SHARED SENSE OF
RESPONSIBILITY. FOR MAINTAINING
AN INCLUSIVE AND HEALTHY
WORKPLACE CULTURE AND FINALLY
THE BILL CLOSES LOOPHOLES.
IN THE LAW THAT HAVE FACILITATED
HARASSMENT.
THE ME TOO MOVEMENT HAS REVEALED
HOW CERTAIN LEGAL TACTICS THINGS
LIKE MANDATORY CONFIDENTIAL
ARBITRATION.
SECRET SETTLEMENTS HAVE PUT THE
LAW TO WORK TO SILENCE VICTIMS
AND SHIELD HARASSERS FROM
ACCOUNTABILITY JUST THINK OF
HARVEY WEINSTEIN.
JUST THINK OF THE WAY THAT MAN
WAS ABLE TO GO ON FOR DECADES
THROUGH THE KINDS OF A
AGREEMENTS THAT HE WAS ABLE TO
EXTRACT FROM PEOPLE WHO WORK FOR
HIM.
AND THAT'S THE OPPOSITE OF HOW
THE LAW SHOULD WORK SO THIS
MEASURE A MEASURE WILL RESTRICT
THE PRACTICE OF IMPOSING SILENCE
ON WORKERS.
THROUGH EMPLOYMENT CONTRACTS
SHOULD HAVE NON DISPARAGEMENT
AGREEMENT AND STOP EMPLOYERS
FROM UTILIZING SNEAKY RELEASES A
PRACTICE IN WHICH WORKERS SIGN
SOME PAPER TO GET POTENTIALLY A
LITTLE REYES FROM A SMALL BONUS
FOR A BIG BONUS.
WITHOUT REALIZING THAT IN FACT
THEY SIGNED THEIR A ROOF RIGHT
AWAY TO SEEK JUSTICE.
THESE ARE THE ITEMS I THINK
THERE'S A FAIRLY COMPREHENSIVE
BILL -- IS A
RECOVERING LAWYER I BELIEVE THAT
WE REALLY HAVE TO BE CLEAR ON
WHAT THE STANDARDS ARE HELP THE
COURTS SO THAT WE CAN DIRECT
THEIR BEHAVIOR INCENTIVIZE
EMPLOYERS.
CORRECT THE PROBLEM BEFORE IT
RISES TO THE LEVEL WHEN LAWSUITS
ARE GOING TO BE OF FORTHCOMING.
AND TO MAKE SURE WE PROTECT
VICTIMS A WITHOUT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AND HAVE WITH ME TODAY PAMELA
LOPEZ A PARTNER A CASE ST
CONSULTING ELIZABETH RILES.
THE MANAGING PARTNER AT BALL
BOUGHT IN ROYALS.
YOU SENATOR PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS ELIZABETH RYALS AND I
AM.
STILL I'M NOT A RECOVERING
LAWYER I AM AN ACTIVE ATTORNEY.
IN OAKLAND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT
LAWYERS ASSOCIATION --
TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THIS BILL.
I THINK WHAT SENATOR JACKSON'S
THAT IS CORRECT WHAT'S ALL TOO
CLEAR.
FROM THE RECENT ME TO MOVEMENT
IS THAT SEXUAL HARASSMENT IS
STILL VERY MUCH A PERVASIVE
PROBLEM INGRAINED IN THE CULTURE
OF OUR WORKPLACES.
I GET CALLS ALL THE TIME FROM
WORKERS WHO HAVE EXPERIENCED
SEXUAL HARASSMENT ON THE JOB.
THEY DESCRIBE HAVING TO DEAL
WITH CO WORKERS AND SUPERVISORS
WHO INSST ON DISCUSSING SEX.
SEXUAL POSITIONS AND THEIR SEX
PARTNERS.
IN ONE RECENT INSTANCE A WOMAN
DESCRIBED TO ME HOW HER CO
WORKERS AND SUPERVISOR WARRANT
COURAGE IN HER TO GO OUT WITH
ANOTHER MAN AT THE OFFICE.
SHE REPEATEDLY REFUSED AND
ULTIMATELY WITH OTHER CO WORKER
FOLLOWED HER INTO A BATHROOM AND
ASSAULTED HER.
SHE COMPLAINED ABOUT THIS AND
WAS TERMINATED FROM HER POSITION.
THESE ARE NOT THE KIND OF WORK
EXPERIENCES THAT CALIFORNIANS
ARE ANYONE SHOULD HAVE TO INDOOR.
YET UNFORTUNATELY THESE
INCIDENTS ARE HAPPENING EVERY
DAY UP AND DOWN THE STATE IN
EVERY KIND OF WORK ENVIRONMENT.
WOMEN FEEL LIKE THEY MUST
OVERCOME THE SEXUALLY HARASSING
CONDUCT AND SOLDIER ON THEY
OFTEN CANNOT AFFORD TO QUIT OR
TAKE TIME OFF.
AND THEY CONTINUED TO WORK
DESPITE EXPERIENCING DEPRESSION.
TRAUMA AND ANXIETY.
THEY SHOULD NEVER BE PENALIZED
IN THEIR SEXUAL HARASSMENT CASE
SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY CONTINUE TO
WORK HARD. TO SUPPORT THEIR
FAMILIES AND WERE PRODUCTIVE
EMPLOYEES DESPITE THE CONDUCT
THAT THEY WERE FORCED TO INDOOR.
S. B. THIRTEEN HUNDRED WILL
ADDRESS SOME OF THESE FAILURES
AND INCONSISTENCIES BY THE COURT
BY PROVIDING STATUTORY GUIDANCE
ON WHAT SEVERE OR PERVASIVE
MEANS. FOR PURPOSES OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT CLAIMS THE BILL WILL
CLARIFY THAT SEXUAL HARASSMENT
MEANS THE CONDUCT OBJECTIVELY
AND SUBJECTIVELY INTERFERED WITH
THE WORKERS ABILITY TO DO OUR
JOB.
A WOMAN SHOULD NOT HAVE TO
SURVIVE HER WORKPLACE SHOULD BE
GIVEN AN EQUAL OPPORTUNITY TO
THRIVE IN IT.
THIS BILL WILL ALSO STRENGTHENED
IN EMPLOYERS DUTY TO PREVENT
HARASSMENT BY MAKING CLEAR THAT
THE DUTY START AS SOON AS THE
EMPLOYER IS AWARE THAT THERE IS
UNWELCOME CONDUCT [inaudible]
FOR EXAMPLE.
I HEARD FROM A POTENTIAL CLIENT
RECENTLY COMPLAINED ABOUT A CO
WORKERS USE OF A WHITE BOARD.
DEPICT SEXUAL MATERIAL POSITIONS
EXETER.
THE EMPLOYER INTERVIEW THE
COMPLAINANT.
BUT THE EMPLOYER DETERMINE THAT
THIS INCIDENT DID NOT RISE TO
THE LEVEL OF SEVERE OR PERVASIVE
AND THEREFORE TOOK NO FURTHER
ACTION.
THIS KIND OF DECISION ENCOURAGES
THE PERPETRATOR TO CONTINUE THIS
KIND OF BEHAVIOR AND EVENTUALLY
TO ESCALATED.
IT ALSO DISCOURAGES EMPLOYEES
FROM COMPLAINING ABOUT.
BEHAVIOR AND CONDUCT THAT THEY
EXPERIENCE S. B. THIRTEEN
HUNDRED TO MAKE IT CLEAR THAT
THE EMPLOYER HAS A DUTY TO STOP
THIS BEHAVIOR FROM THE BEGINNING.
RATHER THAN ALLOW INAPPROPRIATE
OR OFFENSIVE CON TO CONTINUE TO
THE SECOND THIRD OR FOURTH
VICTIM BEFORE FINALLY ESCALATES
TO SEVERE PERVASIVE.
ANOTHER CRITICAL COMPONENT OF
THIS BILL IS BANNING THE LEGAL
TACTIC THAT EMPLOYERS INTERIOR
HARASSERS HAVE USED TO TRYING TO
GET AROUND ANTI HARASSMENT AND
ANTI DISCRIMINATION LAWS.
I'VE SEEN AND MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
SEEN MANY EMPLOYERS THAT REQUIRE
WORKERS TO SIGN VARIOUS LEGAL
DOCUMENTS AS A CONDITION OF
EMPLOYMENT AS A WAY TO SILENCE
VICTIMS ESCAPE LIABILITY.
OR MINIMIZE PUBLIC SCRUTINY.
IN CONCLUSION THIS BILL TAKES A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING SEX HARASSMENT AND
PROVIDES A FRAMEWORK FOR
STRENGTHENING OUR EXISTING LAWS
AND TRAINING REQUIREMENTS.
AND ENSURING THAT THESE RIGHTS
CANNOT BE CONTRA CONTRACTED AWAY
BY DECEPTIVE LEGAL AGREEMENTS
AND FOR THAT I STRONGLY URGE
YOUR AYE [inaudible]
I VOTE.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS GOOD
AFTERNOON --
AYE PAMELA LOPEZ AND I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF WORK EQUITY AND I
AM A SURVIVOR OF SEX WILL
HARASSMENT.
OUR ORGANIZATION SEEKS TO
EMPOWER SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT IN THE FIGHT AGAINST
SEXUAL HARASSMENT SO THAT WE
HAVE A FIGHT --
I OR I HAVE A VOICE IN THIS
EFFORT AND AS A PART OF THIS
WORK I'VE TRAVELED THROUGHOUT
THE STATE AND MET WITH MANY
GROUPS OF WOMEN.
AND MEN WHO HAVE SURVIVED SEXUAL
HARASSMENT OR EVEN SEXUAL
ASSAULT IN THEIR WORKPLACES AND
THEY'VE A LOT TO SAY ABOUT WHAT
OUGHT TO BE DONE TO CHANGE OUR
WORKPLACE CULTURE SO THAT THEY
FEEL SAFE AND CAN CONTRIBUTE
THEIR VERY FAST.
AT WORK AND DOES THEIR
PERSPECTIVE IS WHY WORK EQUITY
SUPPORTS S. B. --
THIRTEEN HUNDRED FIRST AND
FOREMOST EMPLOYERS NEED TO BE
INCENTIVIZED TO IMPROVE WORK
PLACE CULTURE TO MAKE SURE THAT
SEXUAL HARASSMENT DOES NOT OCCUR
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
SP THIRTEEN HUNDRED SUPPORTS
THIS GOAL THROUGH --
STRENGTH AND SEXUAL HARASSMENT
PREVENTION TO I'M MOST IMPORTANT --
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF
SURVIVORS IS THE BYSTANDER
INTERVENTION TRAINING BYSTANDER
INTERVENTION TRAINING GOES A
LONG WAY TOWARD EMPOWERING THOSE
CO WORKERS WHO WISH TO SPEAK UP
WITHOUT BRICK CREATING A
REQUIREMENT THAT THEY DO.
SO THAT THEY CAN HELP THEIR
FELLOW COLLEAGUES FEEL LIKE
SOMEBODY HAS THEIR BACK WHEN WE
SEE SEXUAL HARASSMENT START TO
CREEP UP --
IN THE WORKPLACE.
SHOULD HARASSMENT OR UNWANTED
BEHAVIOR OCCUR IT NEEDS TO STOP
BEFORE IT RISES TO THE LEVEL OF
SEVERE OR PERVASIVE.
UP IN THE WORDS OF MANY
SURVIVORS WITH WHOM I MET I'VE
MET CAN YOU IMAGINE TRYING TO
GET TO A PRESENTATION OR SIT
THROUGH A MEETING WITH A CO
WORKER.
WHO GROPED YOU BUT ONLY DID IT
ONCE HUNT AND SO S. B. --
THIRTEEN HUNDRED HELPS TO
INCENTIVIZE IMMEDIATE ACTION ON
THE PART OF EMPLOYERS WHEN
UNWANTED BEHAVIOR BEGINS TO
OCCUR.
FINALLY S. B. THIRTEEN HUNDRED
HOPES TO PROTECT THE RIGHT OF
SURVIVORS TO TELL OUR STORIES
AND THIS IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT
PART NOT ONLY OF OUR OWN HEALING.
BUT OF OUR ABILITY TO CONTRIBUTE
MEANINGFULLY TO THE EFFORT TO
CHANGE OUR WORKPLACE CULTURES SO
THAT SEXUAL HARASSMENT STOPS
OCCURRING IN THE FIRST PLACE FOR
THESE REASONS WORK EQUITY
SUPPORTS SB THIRTEEN HUNDRED AND
WE HOPE THAT YOU WILL.
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE WORK
OF WORK EQUITY ANYONE ELSE
WISHING TO ADD ON IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
BREAK A OUR CHARLOTTE THE
CALIFORNIA PLUMMET LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION PROUD TO BE A CO
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL ARCHER
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JESSICA CENTER ON BEHALF OF
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES ALSO
PROUD TO SPOT CO SPONSOR THIS
BILL IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SHANNON SMITH GROWING AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
FOR CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
LIKELY ON THE AFTER THEY SELL
YOUR CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION ALSO
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MEMBER FILE LEGAL IT WORK AUSTIN
SUPPORTS.
JOSHUA LOCAL WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
WHEN MRS HERE YOU CALIFORNIA
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU?
I DISCOVERED THAT WHEN THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND TODAY'S OFFERING
SUPPORT FROM THE STRONGER
CALIFORNIA COALITION.
THANK YOU A LOT ELSE TO ADD ON
IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE AND IF THERE'S
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME FORWARD.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MARK CURTIS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE THANK YOU SO
MUCH AGAIN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFY TODAY AT WE ARE HERE
IN OPPOSITION TO SB THIRTEEN
HUNDRED WHICH IS.
ANOTHER JOB KILLER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN THAT IT'S M. WILL CREATE A
CRUSHING AMOUNT OF LITIGATION
FOR EMPLOYERS AND THAT'S OUR
CONCERN AND WE DO APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S TIME DISCUSSING THIS
BILL WITH US --
BUT OUR CONCERNS REMAIN IN THAT.
CURRENTLY UNDER THE LAW AND AS
THE US THAT HAS SENATOR
MENTIONED THERE IS A SEVERE
PERVASIVE STANDARD AND WE SEE
THIS BILL AS A WAY AROUND THAT
SEVERE PERVASIVE STANDARD
BECAUSE YOU NO LONGER ACTUALLY
PROVE THAT HAVE TO PROVE THE
ANYONE SUFFERED FROM HARASSMENT
OR DISCRIMINATION.
IN ORDER TO SUE YOU ONLY HAVE TO
PROVE THAT IT WAS A ANYONE.
SUMMER AND EMPLOYEE A BY
STANDARD CAN BE ANYBODY AND THAT
IT WAS UNWELCOME TO YOU AND THAT
YOU AND NOTIFIED THE EMPLOYER SO
YOU WENT AHEAD AND TOLD THEM
THAT YOU FOUND AND WELCOME AND
THAT THEY FAILED TO TAKE ALL
REASONABLE STEPS.
IN ORDER TO PREVENT THIS
HARASSMENT OR DISCRIMINATION IF
IT WERE TO CONTINUE THEN IT
WOULD BECOME HARASSMENT
DISCRIMINATION NOT THAT IT IS
YET CURRENTLY UNDER THE LAW THE
DF THE AGE HAS POLICE POWER AND
REGARDING PREVENTION OF
HARASSMENT OR DISCRIMINATION AND
EMPLOYERS HAVE AN AFFIRMATIVE
DUTY TO PREVENT HARASSMENT.
OR DISCRIMINATION ABED DE IF THE
H. CAN ENFORCE ANY SORT OF NON
MONETARY REMEDY AGAINST THOSE
EMPLOYERS THAT ARE NOT ARE THAT
ARE FAILING TO PREVENT
HARASSMENT OR DISCRIMINATION.
AND SO OUR CONCERN WITH THIS
BILL IS THAT IT ALLOWS FOR
SOMEONE TO SUE FOR HYPOTHETICAL
NO ONE'S ACTUALLY SUFFERED
HARASSMENT OR DISCRIMINATION AND
THAT YOU CAN BRING A LAWSUIT.
IF I WERE TO CONTINUE TO RUN
THROUGH THE RED LIGHT THEN I
WOULD GET A TICKET IF I STOPPED
AND I SHOULD NOT GET THE TICKET
AND THE DMV AGE HAS UP PLEASE
POWER TO ENFORCE THAT.
AND THAT'S OUR BIGGEST CONCERN
WITH THIS BILL ALONG WITH THE
OTHER AND ISSUES THAT MISTER
MCNEALY WILL MENTION REGARDING
THE ADD NON DISPARAGEMENT
AGREEMENTS AND SEPARATE
AGREEMENTS.
THANK YOU PLEASE PROCEED.
OF VERY QUICKLY MISTER CHAIR IF
I COULD JUST A A SUBDIVISION QUE
FIRST THREE QUICK ITEMS --
THAT IS WHERE THE BILL IS
ATTEMPTING TO POVIDE KEY
GUIDANCE TO THE COURTS AND OUR
CONCERN IS THAT IT SUBSTANTIALLY.
BY LOWERS THE BAR IN
[inaudible]
QUE -- TO
CAP A IT SAYS THAT THE EMPLOYER
KNEW THAT THE CONDUCT WAS
UNWELCOME TO THE PLAINTIFF.
AT WHAT POINT DID THE EMPLOYER
NO BECAUSE THE VICTIM INFORM THE
EMPLOYER THAT THEY HAD PRIOR
NOTICE.
OF WHO IS THE PLAINTIFF IS THE
PLAINTIFF ACTUALLY THE VICTIM.
FOR A THIRD PARTY A BYSTANDER
FOR EXAMPLE WHO FOUND THE
CONDUCT WAS UNWELCOME TO HIM OR
TO HER.
IN SUBDIVISION BE --
QUE TO BE.
IF IT INCREASED.
SO THE WAY I READ THAT LANGUAGE
IS IT ACTUALLY DOESN'T MEET
[inaudible]
THE STANDARD.
BUT IT MIGHT IN THE FUTURE.
AND I THINK MISS CURTIS'S --
ANALOGY TO RUNNING THE RED LIGHT.
A SEEMS APPLICABLE HERE IN OTHER
WORDS.
IF I IT COULD BE THAT I RUN THE
RED LIGHT AND IF I DO I VIOLATED
THE LAW.
BUT THIS ASSUMES THAT IT WILL
ACHIEVE THAT STATUS AND YET
DOESN'T REQUIRE IT.
WHICH IS WHY IT'S A SUBSTANTIAL
LOWERING OF THE BAR.
IF IT IN SUBDIVISION BE IF IT
INCREASED IN SEVERITY OR PRE OR
BECAME PERVASIVE NOT THAT IT IS
WHICH IS THE LEGAL STANDARD
TODAY.
AND THEN IN A AND B. E. CAPS A
AND B. IT USES THE TERM OF ART
THE PHRASE THAT CONDUCT.
AND NOW IN IN SUBDIVISION SEE IT
SAYS SAME OR SIMILAR CONDUCT AND
WHAT EXACTLY IS THAT.
AND LASTLY I WOULD NOTE IN TWO
CAPS SEE.
ALL REASONABLE STEPS WHAT ARE
ALL OF THE REASONABLE STEPS.
BUT YOU KNOW REASONABLE IS QUITE
NEBULOUS ITSELF BUT THEN ALL.
IF YOU DID ONE OR THREE OF THE
REASONABLE ITEMS IS THAT
SUFFICIENT TO STEM LIABILITY OR
NOT.
IN SECTION FOUR OF THE BILL WE
DO HAVE CONCERNS THAT THAT
LANGUAGE --
IS IS GOING TO LIMIT THE ABILITY
TO SETTLE --
CASES HERE --
AND THEN IN SECTION FIVE OF THE
BILL -- THE
PREVAILING PAY PLAINTIFF THE
PREVAILING PARTY GETS ATTORNEYS
FEES AND COSTS.
AND THEN THIS BILL ADDS A MAJOR
EXCEPTION.
EXCEPT FOR THE PREVAILING
DEFENDANT.
IN WHICH CASE WE HAVE A
SUBSTANTIALLY HIGHER THRESHOLD
FOR THE DEFENDANT --
TO RECOVER ATTORNEYS FEES AND
COSTS.
AND WE SHOULD LEAVE EXISTING
WALL AS IS TO THE PREVAILING
PARTY.
YOU CHAIR MEMBERS CALL RICE
CALVARY MANY FACTORS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION I
APPRECIATE YOU ALLOWING ME TO
PROVIDE THIS TESTIMONY WE ARE
ALSO OPPOSED TO THE BILL ON AN
ASSOCIATE OURSELVES WITH THE
COMMENTS AND CONCERNS RAISED BY
THE TWO PREVIOUS SPEAKERS --
BUT WE ALSO HAVE OR OPPOSED TO
AN ADDITIONAL REASON AND THIS
BILL IT'S THE BYSTANDER
INTERVENTION TRAINING --
SP THIRTEEN HUNDRED CREATES THE
SEPARATE AND INDEPENDENT
REQUIREMENT TO TRAIN YOUR
EMPLOYEES ON HOW TO YOU ON
BYSTANDER INTERVENTION AND ASK
THE BILL DESCRIBES IT IT'S IT'S
TAKING ACTION ENCOURAGING THOSE
EMPLOYEES TO TAKE ACTION AND
INTERVENE.
BASED ON THE PERSPECTIVE
PERCEPTION PROBLEMATIC BEHAVIOR
AND IT'S NOT EVEN CLEAR THAT IS
JUST RELATED TO SEXUAL
HARASSMENT IT COULD BE ANY
HARASSMENT OR DISCRIMINATION
SCENE.
AND SEE MTA TAKES ISSUE WITH THE
SUBSTANCE OF THIS TRAINING WE
FEEL THAT IT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY AS EMPLOYERS TO
TRAIN OUR EMPLOYEES ON HOW TO
RECOGNIZE AND HOW TO REPORT
SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
THAT IS INAPPROPRIATE BUT A
TRAINING THEM TO INTERVENE WHEN
WITNESSING SEXUAL HARASSMENT OR
ANY HARASSMENT DISCRIMINATION IN
THE WORKPLACE WE THINK IS NOT
OUR ROLE WERE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE KIND OF LIABILITY THAT WOULD
IMPOSE UPON US AS EMPLOYERS.
BECAUSE WE ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE SAFETY AND HEALTH OF ALL OF
OUR EMPLOYEES --
AND WE ACTUALLY FEEL THAT THE
CONVERSATION THAT'S HAPPENING AT
THE LEGISLATURE ABOUT THE
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES ARE
PROPHESIES THAT NEED TO BE
CHANGED ACTUALLY SUPPORT THIS
KIND OF THINKING.
IN RECENT ANNOUNCEMENTS ABOUT
THE BYSTANDER TRAINING --
AND ENGAGEMENT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS PROPOSING THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT THINGS LIKE
ENCOURAGING THOSE WHO ARE
WITNESSING WHO HAVE WITNESSED
SEXUAL HARASSMENT TO REPORT
THROUGH THE PROPER CHANNELS WE
AGREED THAT IS THE PROPER ROLE
OF THE EMPLOYER. TO ENCOURAGE
OUR EMPLOYEES TO REPORT BUT NOT
TO ENGAGE IN POTENTIALLY GET
THEMSELVES IN A SITUATION THEY
CAN'T HANDLE AND ALSO CREATE
HARM IN THE SITUATION.
WE THINK THAT IS A MUCH MORE
MEASURE APPROACH AND FOR THOSE
REASONS AND THOSE PREVIOUSLY
STATED A WE ARE OPPOSED
ANNOUNCED FOR YOUR NUVO THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS WISHING TO ADD
ON IT OPPOSITION.
TRACY CELLPHONE THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
RESPECT OPPOSITION MAKE YOU.
FAITH FLAME BORDERS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
JOINT POWER AUTHORITIES AND THE
FAMILY BUSINESS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION PICK YOU.
CAITLYN COLEMAN CIVIL JUSTICE
ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION THINK YOU.
KATIE HANSON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED THANK YOU.
I DON'T GIVE US FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
BRIAN LITTLE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FOR THE REASONS OUTLINED
BY MY COLLEAGUES EARLIER IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE ADDING ON OPPOSITION
SEEN NONE TRYING TO THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS.
SOME MEMBER JONES SAWYER HIGH --
IT AND THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS A AND HOPEFULLY GET SOME.
SOME CLARIFICATION IS IS
ESPECIALLY. FOR FOR FOR THE
OPPOSITION LIKE ACT LIKE THINK
GOMM.
IF IF WE HAVE SOME CLARIFYING --
LANGUAGE OR HELPING THEM
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO AS OPPOSED TO WHAT.
I KIND OF READ INTO WHAT YOU'RE
DOING AND I AND EVEN MENTION TO
TO THE OPPOSITION.
ARE EVEN IN MY OWN [inaudible]
WORK.
YEARS --
ORDER FOR SAVE LOS ANGELES I
MENTION TO THEM THAT IF I HAD AN
EMPLOYEE --
WHO SAT IN A CUBICLE AND ABOUT
TEN WOMEN?
TALKING ABOUT BRAD PITT IN SOME
VERY ON SUGGESTED WAYS.
AND AND WHAT THEY WOULD DO TO
HIM.
AND AFTERWARD HE CAME TO ME AND
SAID HE LIKED IT.
IT WAS A CHRISTIAN.
AND THAT WAS THE PROBLEM.
BEEN A MALE TALK TO ANOTHER MALE.
AND I WAS SUPERVISE ALL THE
SUPERVISORS.
I SAID SOME BE TOTALLY
INAPPROPRIATE BUT TIME.
I SAID NO.
ANYONE IN WOMEN WENT.
TO DO WHICH ARE SIGNED YOU UP
GLAD TO ANY LOOKED AT ME AND
SAID.
AND MY SON'S A CHRISTIAN.
AND I IMMEDIATELY.
MY EYES GOT LIKE THIS BIG THEM
REALLY AND I WENT TO OUR
PERSONNEL.
WHO EXPLAINED TO ME THAT ONE MY
COMMENT WAS INAPPROPRIATE? TO
THAT I NEEDED TO HAVE MORE
TRAINING.
AND I REALIZED I DID.
NEED MORE TRAINING ABOUT THIRD
PARTY OUT SITE.
OBSERVING WHAT THEY PERCEIVE AS
SEXUAL HARASSMENT IT WASN'T
ABOUT WHAT I PERCEIVED.
S. SEXUAL HARASSMENT BUT WHAT.
A PERSON WHO'S EXPERIENCING IT.
THAT'S WHAT EVERITT IS A SEXUAL
HARASSMENT TO THEM.
I'M NOT GOING TO MAKE THAT
JUDGMENT.
IF WHAT THE FOR THE TRAINING.
THE ONE FOR PERSONNEL ONE FOR
SOMEBODY. TO TALK TO ME AS A AS
A MANAGER AS A SUPERVISOR TO
CORRECT ME.
I PROBABLY STILL WOULD BE MAKING
THE SAME MISTAKES OVER AND OVER
AND OVER AGAIN.
AND SO I I I UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO.
WITH THE TRAINING I UNDERSTAND
WHAT YOU WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
ABOUT THIRD PARTY BECAUSE IT IS
VERY IMPORTANT --
FOR MEN.
NOW SAID THE MAN --
WELL WE HEAR ANOTHER MAN
[inaudible]
MAKE [inaudible]
COMMENTS [inaudible]
ABOUT --
COLLEAGUES BODY PARTS OR WHAT
THEY WOULD DO WE NEED TO SHUT IT
DOWN.
BECAUSE IT'S NOT GOING TO GO
AWAY UNTIL WE ACTIVELY SHUT IT
DOWN.
TO AND WE GET INVOLVED SO I ALSO
UNDERSTAND.
WHAT YOU TRYING TO DO BECAUSE?
A LOT OF THE PROBLEM IS WITH US.
AND A LOT OF THE REMIS THIS WILL
BE WITH US.
AND AND SO I APPLAUD YOU ON WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO AND
HOPEFULLY.
EITHER IN YOUR CLOSING --
ORG SOMEWHERE ALONG THIS LINE
YOU KIND OF CLARIFY WHICH ARE
REAL ATTENTIVE AND IN DOING THIS.
AND IT'S REALLY ABOUT NAM MAKING
THIS A SAFE AND SECURE WORKPLACE
FOR EVERYONE --
EN AND WEATHER XIN MANUFACTURE --
AND COMMERCIAL PROPERTY --
OR IN THE CAPITAL.
ON IT IT'S ABOUT.
DOING THE RIGHT THING AND THEN
REALLY UNDERSTANDING
[inaudible]
THAT.
THAT SEXUAL HARASSMENT IS WHAT I
DEFINE.
IT'S WHAT IT IS.
AND THAT WE WE'VE JUST WHICH GOT
A BETTER AT IT BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
WE'RE PROBABLY LIVING IN A
NINETEEN SIXTIES MADMAN KINDA.
CUT UP UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT IT
IS AND IT'S WRONG WHO AND UNTIL
WE UNDERSTAND IT'S DISAVOWED IN.
EIGHTEEN AND NINETEEN EIGHTEEN
OF IT WILL CONTINUE TO GO ON A
LONG SOUGHT AGAIN I APPLAUD
UNITE AND HONESTLY BELIEVE.
IF ON BUSINESS WORKS WITH YOU.
AND DOES THE RIGHT THING BECAUSE
I NOTE SINCE I DID THE RIGHT
THING.
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES.
WOULD NOT BE SUIT WHO WHO.
BECAUSE I WENT BACK.
AND LATER TOLD HEAD A MEETING
WITH ALL MY EMPLOYEES.
AND SHUT DOWN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AMONG ANYONE IN
THE OFFICE.
THEY MADE THAT AND PERSON OUT A
MEMO AND MADE THAT A DIRECTIVE
THAT WE WOULD NOT HAVE NO MATTER
HOW INNOCENT OR YOU MAY THINK IT
IS WE WOULD NO LONGER HAVE THOSE
SIDEBAR CONVERSATIONS NEAR WATER
COOLER.
OF ANY KIND ANYWHERE AND I
SATISFIED THAT PERSON
[inaudible]
WHICH KEPT US FROM HAVING A
LAWSUIT.
BUT AGAIN IT'S ALLOWING THAT
PERSON TO TALK TO YOU.
I TALK TO SOMEBODY RESPONSIBLE
THAT KNOWS WHAT TO DO THAT'S
BEEN TRAINED --
YOU CAN AVOID ALL SORTS OF
LITIGATION.
AND HAVE A BETTER WORKPLACE SO
HOPEFULLY NAM.
YOU CAN CLARIFY SOME OF THAT
MAKE ME HAPPY TUNE APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS.
THE OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO ADD
TO THE DISCUSSION.
SEEING NONE LOOKING FOR MOTION.
BILL'S BEEN MOVED OFF SECOND
SENATOR WOULD LIKE CLOSE THANK
YOU I APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION
AND I CONTINUE TO BE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH THE CHAMBER.
WHICH JUST NOT READING THE SAME
PILL.
ARE IS A LAWYER AND WORKING WITH
LAWYERS THE INTERPRETATION THAT
WORD HEARING IS JUST NOT.
ACCURATE CAUGHT UP BUT I AM MORE
THAN HAPPY WE HAVE TAKEN SOME
AMENDMENTS TO REINFORCE THE FACT
THAT YOU HAVE.
TO HAVE BEEN VICTIMIZED TO HAVE
STANDING YOU CAN'T NOBODY IT'S
NOT JUST ANYBODY CAN SUE --
THE YEAH IF YOU REPORT A A TWO
HR THAT SOMEONE'S BEHAVING IN AN
INAPPROPRIATE SEXUALIZED MANNER
TOWARDS YOU IN THE WORKPLACE.
YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO EXPECT THE
HR TO TAKE REASONABLE STEPS TO
STOP THAT AND IN FACT THAT'S
WHAT THE BILL DOES IT SAYS.
IF YOU.
A HAVE EXPERIENCE AND THE
EXPERIENCE BEHAVIOR WHICH IS ON
WELCOMED IT'S NOT THAT THE
EMPLOYER SHOULDN'T ALL.
WE'VE MADE WE TIED IT UP IT'S
THAT THE EMPLOYEE HAS GONE TO
THE EMPLOYER.
SO EMPLOYERS DON'T HAVE TO GUESS.
THIS BILL SAYS THE EMPLOYER
KNOWS AND THE EMPLOYER'S GONNA
NOLL BECAUSE THEY KNOW BECAUSE
SOMEONE STOLE THEM.
SO THAT'S ONE ISSUE --
THE A EMPLOYEES CAN'T SUE FOR A
LITTLE THING THEY FIND
INAPPROPRIATE ARE UNWELCOME IN
THE WORKPLACE --
THAT I'D LIKE TO USE THE ANALOGY
THAT THE CHAMBER USED IF YOU RUN
A RED LIGHT.
YOU'RE ENTITLED TO A CITATION
YOU VIOLATED THE LAW BUT IF YOU
STOP BEFORE YOU GET TO THE RED
LIGHT.
YOU HAVEN'T DONE ANYTHING WRONG.
AND THAT'S THE ESSENCE OF WHAT
THIS BILL IS THAT THAT IS TRYING
TO DO AND I BELIEVE THE LANGUAGE
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK TO
CLARIFY IF THERE'S ANY QUESTION
ABOUT THAT.
YOU DON'T GET YOUR NOT GONNA GET
SUED UNTIL YOU RUN THROUGH THAT
RED LIGHT.
AND SO --
THAT THAT IS --
AYE I THINK.
AGAIN I I THINK FRANKLY THIS IS
JUST THAT THE FOLKS WHO OR POST
THIS BILL DON'T WANT THE BILL.
A BUT WE'VE TIGHTENED UP THE
LANGUAGE THE NOTION OF BYSTANDER --
TRAINING IT DOESN'T SAY
BYSTANDER INTERVENTION.
IT SHOWS US TRAINING.
SO THAT IF A BY STANDER WANTS TO
INTERVENE.
THERE'S NO ROOM THERE'S NO
LIABILITY IF THEY DON'T THERE'S
NO MANDATE THAT THEY INTERVENE
IT'S TRUST THAT WE'RE GOING TO
GIVE PEOPLE THE TOOLS SO THEY IF
THEY FEEL COMPELLED OR IF THEY
FEEL EMPOWERED.
THINGS HAD A VERY SIMPLE LIKE
HELPING MOVE THE VICTIM AWAY
FROM A DANGEROUS SITUATION WE'RE
DOING THIS NOW WITH COLLEGE
STUDENTS AND IN FACT IT IS
WORKING.
SO LET'S DO THIS IN THE
WORKPLACE GIVE PEOPLE THE TOOLS
THAT'S ALL WE DO.
A UNDER THIS AND THEN THE NOTION
OF ATTORNEYS FEES AND COSTS.
ALL WE'RE DOING IS MIRRORING
EXISTING CIVIL RIGHTS LAW.
SO THERE'S NOTHING NEW HERE
THAT'S THE LAW TODAY IN THE
CIVIL RIGHTS ACTION --
I DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S ANYTHING
ELSE THAT I MISSED --
BUT I WILL ASSURE YOU THAT I
WILL CONTINUE --
TO WORK --
AND HAD IS RECENTLY AS YESTERDAY
AT A MEETING WITH THE CHAMBER
FOLKS TO TALK ABOUT THEIR
CONCERNS IF THERE'S A WAY WE CAN
TWEAK THE LANGUAGE THERE IS NOT
GOING TO BE A CRUSHING AMONG THE
LITIGATION.
ANYMORE SO THAT WE'RE SEEING
TODAY AS THAT DAM HAS FINALLY
BROKEN AS THE MATT LAUER'S AS
THE YEAH HARVEY WEINSTEIN'S AND
THE LIST GOES ON AND ON AND ON%
WOMEN ARE FINALLY WILLING TO
STEP FORWARD.
AND TAKING DOWN --
SOME VERY WHO HAVE BEEN ALLOWED
FOR DECADES TO BEHAVE IN A WAY
THAT IS JUST CONTRARY TO WHAT IS
APPROPRIATE IN TODAY'S WORLD.
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS
DESIGNED TO DO WE MAINTAIN A
VERY HIGH STANDARD.
I COULD REDUCE THAT STANDARD TO
SOMETHING MUCH MUCH LOWER THEN
YOU'D SEE A FLOODGATE OF
LITIGATION.
BUT THE GOAL HERE IS TO GET
COMPLIANCE. TO AVOID LITIGATION
IF WE CAN BUT NOT TO PUT VICTIMS
OF THIS BEHAVIOR AT A
DISADVANTAGE LET'S EDUCATE
PEOPLE LET'S INFORM THEM LET'S
PREVENT AND LET'S PUT A HAMMER
IF WE CAN'T GET PEOPLE TO START
BEHAVING PROPERLY AND COMPANIES
TO DOING THE SAME WITH THAT I
WOULD ASK YOUR I'VE.
THANK YOU SENATORS BILL AT THE
TO PASS RECOMMENDATION PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE THURMAN AYE
AYE THURMOND AYE FLORA.
FLORA NOW GONZALEZ FLETCHER
JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE KALRA BEAVIS
[inaudible]
STEINORTH [inaudible]
STEINORTH NO.
THOSE OLD CALL AWAY FOR OTHERS
TO BE OBJECTIVE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN GIVES.
WE SEE THAT SENATOR WINNER IS
HERE TO PRESENT A FILE ITEM
THREE SB NINE THREE SEVEN
WELCOME SENATOR.
THANK YOU PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
READY.
BOB THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
FOR HEARING THAT'S INCALLING
THANK YOU POT THIS IS THE FIFTH
TIME I'M PRESENTING THIS BILL
WE'RE TRICKLE REFERRED IN THE
SENATE DOUBLE REFERRED.
BY IN THE ASSEMBLY AND HOPE WE
REFLECT REPLY SO I'LL DO MY BEST --
SERIOUSLY --
DODD S. B. --
NINE THIRTY SEVEN WILL I AM SURE
THAT --
WOMEN WHO RETURNED TO WORK AFTER
A GIVING BIRTH --
ARE ABLE --
TO EXPRESSED BREAST MILK MILKER
ABLE TO LACKEY AYE IN --
COMFORTABLE INAPPROPRIATE ALL
PRIVATE ON MATTER --
SO THAT.
WOMEN CAN DECIDE FOR THEMSELVES
ARE GOING TO RETURN TO WORK AND
AREN'T CONSTRAINED BECAUSE THEY
FEEL LIKE THEY MUST STAY HOME.
OUGHT -- TO
TO TO BE ABLE TO BREASTFEED HOT
NEW MOTHERS SHOULD BE ABLE TO DO
BOTH RETURNED TO WORK.
ON ALSO BREAST FEED --
AND LACTIC FOR THEIR ON YOUR
CHILD OUT WE KNOW THAT --
WHEN OUR MOTHERS ARE EVIL --
TO BREASTFEEDING LACTATE ABOUT
THE BABY EYES HEALTHIER --
HAS BETTER OUTCOMES --
AND THE FAMILY I WAS GOING TO BE
A HEALTHIER AND SO IT'S
SOMETHING WE DEFINITELY WANT TO
I ENCOURAGE.
UNFORTUNATELY RIGHT NOW ALTHOUGH
EMPLOYERS ARE REQUIRED TO MAKE
AN ACCOMMODATION FOR A WOMAN --
TO EXPRESSED BREAST MILK ARE THE
STANDARDS OF VERY LOW BASICALLY
THAT YOU CAN'T FORCE THEM INTO
OSCILLATORY WHAT WILL THEY DO IT
AND I THINK WE WANT TO TAKE IT
UP A NOTCH [inaudible]
FIRES ARE EMPLOYERS BUT BEHALF.
ON PROVIDE A A PRIVATE SPACE --
FOR FOR THE SKIN FOR BREAST
MARIN LACTATION TO OCCUR --
AND I NEED YOU CAN BE A ROOM A
COULD BE A TEMPORARY STRUCTURE
CREATES A LOT OF FLEXIBILITY --
IN THE BILL NOT WITH A TABLE AND
A CHAIR AND WITH OUR
REFRIGERATOR SOMEWHERE NEARBY --
SO THAT I AYE SHE CAN STORE THE%
MILK AFTER ON LACTATING --
THAT ARE BILL --
ALSO REQUIRES THAT FOR I KNEW A
CONSTRUCTION OVER FIFTEEN
THOUSAND SQUARE FEET --
THE BUILDING CODES I WILL HAVE
TO BE UPDATED OUT TO MAKE SURE
THE BUILDINGS FROM THE OUTSIDE.
HAVE THE SPACE UP THERE'S A LOT
OF FLEXIBILITY FOR EXAMPLE
COMMERCIAL TENANTS IN A MULTI
SPACE OFFICE BUILDING A MALL OR
ABLE TO SHARE --
LACTATION --
SPACES OF IT ALL OUGHT TO HAVE
THEIR OWN BUT AS I MENTIONED IF
YOU ARE UNDER A LOT OF
FLEXIBILITY FOR EXAMPLE REALLY
SMALL RETAIL SPACE.
MAY NOT BE ABLE TO HAVE A
SEPARATE ROOM BUT MIGHT BE ABLE
TO HAVE.
A YEAR TEMPORARY PRIVACY
STRUCTURE OUGHT TO ENSURE THAT --
LIKE TEACHING CAN OCCUR IN
PRIVATE ON THE WE WORKED CLOSELY
AND EXTENSIVELY WITH THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY.
AYE THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS AND
OF NEGOTIATED AND TAKEN A SERIES
OF AMENDMENTS ODD THAT STILL
MAINTAIN A STRONG BILL ABU TRIED
TO REALLY ADDRESS SOME OF THE
LOGISTICAL.
OUR CONCERNS EXPRESSED BY THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY UP THERE IS A
LOT POTENTIAL HARDSHIP EXEMPTS
EXEMPTION FOR ANY EMPLOYER UP TO
FIFTY EMPLOYEES.
IBEC CAN BE LITIGATED EITHER --
WITH THE LABOR COMMISSIONER OR
IN COURT ABOUT EMPLOYEE DISPUTES
THE HARDSHIP.
THE CLAIM OF HARDSHIP BY THE
EMPLOYER OUGHT BUT AGAIN WHICH
IS WHEN WE GET SOME LEVEL OF OUR
FLEXIBILITY --
V. I BILL ALSO ARE --
PROTECTS OUR PEOPLE FROM
RETALIATION --
FOR CLAIMING THESE RIGHTS --
AND ALSO REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT
OF LABOR STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT
OUGHT TO ISSUE ON BEST PRACTICES
OFFER LACTATION ACCOMMODATION IS
BEST PRACTICES WOULD NOT BE
BINDING ON WE'VE INCLUDED A
PROVISION THAT YOU CAN'T USE.
IT AS EVIDENCE AND THE LOSS TO
AND OTHER WORDS WE DON'T IS NOT
MEANT.
TO FORCE BUSINESSES TO COMPLY
BUT FOR BUSINESSES THAT DO WANT
TO GO ABOVE AND BEYOND THE LEGAL
MINIMUM.
OUT WE WANT THE STATE TO PROVIDE
THAT GUIDANCE ON WHAT GOD ABOVE
AND BEYOND IS.
ODD SO --
COLLEAGUES SO THIS IS A AN
OVERDUE BILL AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE --
WITH ME TODAY OUR IDENTITY GARY.
AND DR I FROM THE CALIFORNIA
BREASTFEEDING BECAUSE THANK YOU.
I'M -- MY
NAME IS A KICKER ALLY I
REPRESENT HEALTH CHRISTIAN
COALITION [inaudible]
COME CHAIRMAN.
TERMIN AND MEMBERS OF THE CULT
FOR BREASTFEEDING COALITION IS
PLEASED.
TO S. COSPONSORED THIS BILL --
BECAUSE IT ADDRESSES BARRIERS
FACED BY NEW PARENTS.
WHO RETURNED TO WORK AFTER BIRTH
THEIR BABIES --
A SPEED NINE THIRTY SEVEN
ADDRESSES BERRIES THAT MAKE IT
DIFFICULT TO MAINTAIN
BREASTFEEDING.
WHILE JUGGLING THE
RESPONSIBILITIES OF RETURNING TO
WORK AND WISHING TO PROVIDE THE
BEST PATRICIA POSSIBLE. FOR THE
NEWBORNS --
INDISCREET NINE THIRTY SEVEN
PROVIDES MUCH NEEDED GUIDANCE TO
EMPLOYERS ON HOW TO SUPPORT
ELECTED EMPLOYEES TO INCREASE
[inaudible]
PRESSING DURATION.
WHICH IN RETURN WOULD BENEFIT
THE BOTTOM LINE OF BUSINESS IS
BY DECREASING.
WORKER ABSENTEEISM.
RETENTION AND RECRUITMENT.
HUMAN MILK IS THE BEST SOURCE OF
NUTRITION. FOR INFANTS AND IT'S
IMPORTANT TO IMPROVE THE
WORKPLACE. TO SUPPORT MOTHERS TO
GIVE ONLY PRESIDENT TO THEIR
INFANTS FOR THE FIRST MONTHS OF
THERE BABY'S LIFE AND TO
CONTINUE PROVIDE.
BREASTMILK FOR THE FOR AT LEAST
THE FIRST YEAR OF LIFE.
AND THIS IS THE IT THAT THIS IS
AGREED UPON BY.
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION IN AMERICAN
ACCOUNT PEDIATRICS.
WRESTLING REDUCES ALL SO RISK
AVERSE MANY SHORTEN LONG TERM
HEALTH CONDITIONS.
BOTH FOR INFANTS AND THEIR
MOTHERS. FOR INFANTS
BREASTFEEDING CONTRIBUTES TO
DECREASE RISK OF EAR INFECTIONS
DIARRHEA PNEUMONIA [inaudible]
GASTROENTERITIS IN ITS HAS BEEN
SHOWN TO BE SOCIAL WITH
DECREASED RISK OF SUDDEN INFANT
DEATH SYNDROME WHICH IS.
AFFLICTING OF MANY COMMUNITIES
IN CALIFORNIA. FOR MOTHER'S
BREAST REALLY PROVIDES
TREMENDOUS HEALTH BENEFITS.
INCLUDING DECREASE RISK OF
DEVELOPING TYPE TWO DIABETES.
DECREASE RISK FOR BREAST AND
OVARIAN CANCER.
RHEUMATOID ARTHRITIS HIGH BLOOD
PRESSURE AND HIGH CHOLESTEROL.
FOR PARENTS OF BABIES BORN
PREMATURELY.
BREASTFEEDING IS OF VERY
SPECIFIC IMPORTANCE.
BECAUSE IT SIGNIFICANTLY
DECREASES THE RISK OF
NECROTIZING ENTEROCOLITIS WHICH
IS AN ILLNESS STAT.
AFFLICTS MANY PREMATURE BABIES
WHO ARE IN THE NEONATAL
INTENSIVE CARE UNIT FOR MONTHS.
AND AND AND PREVENTS THEIR DEATH.
IF -- 90% OF
CALIFORNIA WOMEN WHERE ABLE TO
BREASTFEED IN ACCORDANCE WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS.
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS WOULD BE
SAVED. ONE STUDY ESTIMATED
SAVINGS AT OVER TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS.
OF DIRECT HEALTHCARE COSTS
ANNUALLY.
BREASTFEEDING IS GOOD FOR
BUSINESS.
EMPLOYERS WOULD LACTATION
SUPPORT PROGRAMS HAVE EXPERIENCE
HIGHER PRODUCTIVITY.
EMPLOYEE JOB SATISFACTION MORALE
AND ENHANCE LOYAL TO THEIR
COMPANY.
ELECTIVE XIN SUPPORT PROGRAM CAN
BE IN ADDED RECRUITMENT
INCENTIVE FOR FEMALE EMPLOYEES.
AND CAN HIT ENHANCE A COMPANY'S
IMAGE IN THE COMMUNITY.
I THINK THIS TOPIC IS ONE OF
THOSE ISSUES WHERE THAT THE
INTERESTS OF THE EMPLOYEES.
AND EMPLOYERS AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ORAL FELLOW LINES.
POLY AND HEAR OF MY TESTIMONY
AND ASK FOR YOUR HIGH WALLS.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
ARMONK AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JENNA GARY AND AN ATTORNEY WITH
LEGAL AID AWARE WHERE A
NONPROFIT PUBLIC INTEREST LEGAL
ORGANIZATION.
THAT ADVOCATE ON THE RIGHT ON
BEHALF OF LOW WAGE WORKERS.
SOME ANA BE HERE TODAY AS A CO
SPONSOR EXPRESSED STRONG SUPPORT
FOR S. B. NINE THIRTY SEVEN AND
I WANT TO THANK SENATOR WIENER.
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE.
SIMPLY PUT SB NINE THIRTY SEVEN
BUTCHER ALL LACTATING PARENT
ABLE TO MEET THE MOST BASIC NEED
OF THEIR CHILD'S [inaudible]
PROVIDING FOOD.
AT LEGALLY THAT WHERE WE HAVE A
WORKING FAMILY HELP LINE WHERE
WE HEAR FROM ABOUT FIFTEEN
HUNDRED TWO THOUSAND EMPLOYEES
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WHO ARE STRUGGLING WITH BEING
PARENTS AND EMPLOYEES.
AND FAR TOO OFTEN WE HEAR FROM
INDIVIDUALS WHO LACK PROPER.
ADEQUATE LACTATION SUPPORTS FOR
EXAMPLE I JUST WANNA SHARE ONE
STORY OF OUR CLIENT TARA.
CHARACTERS A WAITRESS AT A
RESTAURANT WHICH HAD OUR FIRST
CHILD.
AFTER RETURNING TO WORK TARA
WANTED TO CONTINUE BREASTFEEDING
HER CHILD.
AND ASK YOUR EMPLOYER FOR
LACTATION ACCOMMODATIONS.
UNFORTUNATE HARRIS TOLD THE ONLY
SPACE HAD WAS A REFRIGERATED ONE
ROOM WITH NO ACCESS TO
ELECTRICITY.
NO PLACE TO SAID NO PLACE TO PUT
THE PALM.
AND SUCH IS LEFT WITH THE SOLE
OPTION OF EITHER STOPPING BREAST
FEEDING HER QUITTING HER JOB AND
RISKING SEVERE FINANCIAL
HARDSHIP.
EMPLOYERS ARE NOT BILL THETAKE
THAT DECISION AWAY FROM A NEW
PARENT.
S. B. NINE THIRTY WILL OPEN
JAPAN'S LIKE TARA ARE ABLE TO
MAKE THE RIGHT DECISIONS FOR
THEMSELVES AND THEIR CHILDREN.
S. B. NINE THIRTY SEVEN PRIDE
SIMPLE SOLUTION TO ADDRESS THESE
CRITICAL DISPARITIES IN HEALTH
AND EQUITY.
THAT WERE DISCUSSED HERE TODAY
BY ALIGNING MINIMUM STANDARDS
FOR THE SPACE AND PRACTICES THAT
WILSHIRE WORKERS RECEIVE SUPPORT
OF LACTATION ACCOMMODATIONS.
STUDIES SHOW THAT SIX MONTHS
EMPLOYED PARENTS RECEIVE
LACTATION ABOUT AGENTS. TWO
POINT THREE TIMES AS LIKELY TO
EXCLUSIVELY BREASTFEED.
COMPARED TO THOSE WHO DO NOT
HAVE ADEQUATE LACTATION SUPPORTS
AT WORK.
SIMILARLY AT SIX MONTHS EMPLOYED
PARENTS RECEIVE BREASTFEEDING
COMBINATIONS ARE ONE POINT FIVE
TIMES AS LIKELY TO EXCLUSIVELY
BREASTFEED WITH EACH PASSING
MONTH COMPARED OF THOSE WHO
DON'T.
THAT'S FOR THESE REASONS REVIEW
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION TO SUPPORT
BREASTFEEDING PARENTS AND THEIR
CHILDREN.
A FEW OTHERS WISHING TO ADD ON
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ALICE KESSLER HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF OBSTETRICIANS AND
GYNECOLOGISTS DISTRICT NINE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
AS CHAIR MEMBERS BRIAN HOW WITH
THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS OUR ENTIRE MEMBERSHIP
VOTED TO COSPONSOR THIS VERY
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION THANK YOU
[inaudible]
IF YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DAVID
JONES ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
GLENDALE COMMISSION ON THE
STATUS OF WOMEN AND GIRLS STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CATHERINE OF ARAGON ON BEHALF OF
FIRST HAVE CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION ALSO
HERE SUPPORT AQ.
LIKELY ON THE HALF THE ACLU A
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DANIELLE CANADA KAISER ON BEHALF
OF COMMON SENSE KIDS ACTION IN
STRONG SUPPORT [inaudible]
YOU.
A MARK SHOCK PROCEDURAL A
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
YOU.
JESSICA SENATOR WITH EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES IN THE STRONGER
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES NETWORK IN
STRONG SUPPORT THE QUEUE OTHERS
WISHING AT ON IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION
PLEASE COME FORWARD [inaudible]
PLEASE PROCEED.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON LARA CURTIS
CAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE WE ARE HERE ON AND
OPPOSE MUST AMENDED POSITION ON
THIS BILL AND WE DO WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH AND THE AUTHOR AND
FOR WORKING WITH US SO MUCH ON
THIS BILL --
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING ON AMEND
AMENDMENTS BUT IT SEEMS LIKE
WE'RE AT A POINT WHERE AND WERE
AT THEIR STILL OUTLINED CONCERNS
AND THAT HAVEN'T BEEN AT TAKING
CARE OF IT.
AT THIS POINT THE BIGGEST ONE IS
THE BUILDING CODE REQUIREMENTS
RIGHT NOW SO THIS BILL AS THE
SENATOR SAID WAS STRUCTURED
AFTER SAN FRANCISCO ORDINANCE
BUT AS YOU ALL KNOW SAN
FRANCISCO IS MUCH DIFFERENT THAN
THE REST OF CALIFORNIA.
AND SO THINGS THAT OCCUR IN
HUMANS IS GO DON'T ALWAYS WORK
FOR THE REST OF THE STATE AND M.
AIDS A FROM THE STATISTICS THAT
WE'VE RECEIVED AS IT WOULD COST
EMPLOYERS APPROXIMATELY THIRTY
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS JUST TO MAKE A
VERY BASIC LACTATION ROOM.
AN ADDITION IT'S GOING TO COST
EMPLOYERS AT APPROXIMATELY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO FOURTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR MAINTENANCE
OF THAT ROOM ANNUALLY AND SO
THAT'S OUR BIGGEST CONCERN I'M
IS THE COST FOR THESE WHILE THE
BILL DOES ALLOW FOR A TEMPORARY
STRUCTURE.
IT DOESN'T ALLOW FOR A TEMPORARY
STRUCTURE IF YOU HAVE A REMODEL
THE MILLION DOLLARS OR IF YOU
ARE AND THAT SPACES FIFTEEN
THOUSAND SQUARE FEET.
SO THE TEMPORARY STRUCTURE ONLY
ALLOWS.
FOR THAT WON'T BE MAKING
UPGRADES ADDITIONALLY IN SAN
FRAN SAN FRANCISCO ORDINANCE
THERE IS NOT A PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION AND OUR BIGGEST CONCERN
IS THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
BECAUSE OF THE LITIGATION THAT
WILL COME FROM THIS.
EVEN IF YOU WERE TO PROVIDE AN
ACCOMMODATION TO THE MOTHER
UNDER THIS BILL YOU COULD STILL
BE CAUGHT UP IN LITIGATION OVER
THE VERY TECHNICAL ISSUES FOR
EXAMPLE THE MAINTENANCE OF THE
RECORDS AND THE NOTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS AND AND ISSUES LIKE
THAT.
AND SO WE'VE ASKED THAT THE
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION BE
STRUCK AS WELL AS THE BUILDING
CODE CONSTRUCTION AND THAT WOULD
TAKE CARE OF THE BIGGEST ISSUES
WITH THE BILL WE OF COURSE WOULD
STILL HAVE.
OTHER AND CLARIFYING LANGUAGE
THAT WE WOULD CONTINUE TO WORK
ON BUT THOSE ARE TWO BIGGEST
CONCERNS THANKS SO MUCH AGAIN
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO THEY Q. OTHERS WISHING TO ADD
ON OPPOSITION.
FAVORING BORDERS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
JOINT POWER AUTHORITIES WOULD
ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH THOSE
MISS CURTIS RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
MUST MANDATE [inaudible]
IF YOU.
REX W. HIME ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S PROP IS ASSOCIATION
ALIGNING WITH THE COMMENTS AS
WELL AS FROM THE CONCERNS OF OUR
MEMBERS AND SANDWICHES QUERY
ALREADY ARE RESPECTFULLY POST
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON DOROTHY JOHNSON
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES OPPOSE
LAWS A MINUTE FOR THE REASONS
PREVIOUSLY STATED THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
CAITLYN COLEMAN CIVIL JUSTICE
ASSOCIATION AND OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
KATIE HANSON HERE THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED AS WELL.
MAKE YOU.
AND THE CALL RICE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURES AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION ALSO POSE LISTEN AND
BAKE YOU ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO
OPPOSE I HAVE A QUESTION --
FOR THE CHAMBER IN THEIR
OPPOSITION --
BUT IT IT WHILE THEY COME
FORWARD AND THE OTHER MEMBERS
WITH QUESTION OR A COMMENT FOR
DISCUSSION.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES SAWYER.
OKAY AND THANK YOU I'M ACTUALLY
I BOTH PERSONAL AND A AND BUCKET
A PROFESSIONAL QUESTION.
SO WHAT I'M.
OPTIONS I'M A PROUD GRANDFATHER
WITH THE NEW.
WITH A VERY NEW A GRANDSON WHO'S
ABOUT THREE MONTHS AND HE'S VERY
HEALTHY BECAUSE OF BREAST MILK.
WHILE MY DAUGHTER IS A TEACHER
IN LA UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
SO I'M I HEARD CTA IF SCHOOL
DURING FOR OFFICIAL DISTANCE
COVER GOVERNMENTAL.
IT'S CHILLY SO WILL THIS
FACILITY AFTER COMING DEADLINES
ALSO.
YES AND ALL SCHOOL YES.
OKAY DOT CORRECT AND AT LEAST.
FIRE STATIONS --
EVERYONE WILL HAVE TO BE IN
COMPLIANCE AND IN FACT THE AS
THE CHAMBER INDICATED --
THEY TALK ABOUT THE SAN
FRANCISCO ART ORDINANCE NAM OF
COURSE OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
CANNOT TELL SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
WHAT TO DO THROUGH SAN FRANCISCO
ORDINANCE DOES NOT COVER OF SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT?
ARE AND SO THERE IS A REAL VALUE
FOR FOR EXAMPLE TO DOING THIS AT
THE STATE LEVEL.
DAY AND THEN ON A PROFESSIONAL
IT PROBABLY [inaudible]
MAYBE THAT.
MAYBE ONLY PERSON IN THIS WHOLE
BUILDING.
THAT'S EVER MANAGE THE GROUP OF
PEOPLE THAT HAD TO PUT IN BOTH
LACTATION AND DIAPER CHANGING
FACILITIES EN A COMMERCIAL
BUILDING.
AND MAKING SURE I DO REMEMBER --
CITY COUNCIL BEING VERY VERY.
ANXIOUS TO GET THIS DONE VERY
HAPPY TO GET THIS DONE.
AND THEN WHEN I PRESENTED THAT
BUDGET BILL ALL THE SUDDEN
AIRBASE ARE LOOKING.
IN A POINT FINGERS AND ONE TO
TAKE MONEY OUT OF MY*.
AND ALSO WE COULD AFFORD IT.
AND SELL OUT I AM.
I AM CONCERNED ABOUT MAKING SURE.
IT CAN GET DONE --
AND AND HOPEFULLY YOU'VE PUT IN
ENOUGH MEASURES AND I THINK
THAT'S KIND OF WHERE WE'RE GOING
WHERE WE CAN.
WE GET THIS DONE COULD THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING IS.
TO HAVE THE ABILITY ON YOUNG
MOTHERS TO PROVIDE UP BREAST
MILK TO TO TWO YOUNG KIDS I'M
EVEN.
IBM PUT MY BILL MY OWN TO BOOK
SO THAT I'M.
INCARCERATED WOMEN WE'LL BE ABLE
TO PRODUCE BREASTMILK AND GIVE
TO THEIR GIVE THEIR CHILDREN AND
EXCITING UP OTHERS IT IS VERY
VERY IMPORTANT --
BUT ALSO KNOW HOW DIFFICULT IT
IS TO CHANGE THE BATHROOM AND TO
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO CLEANLINESS.
BEING ABLE TO MAINTAIN IT --
IF YOU PUT ONE IN I HAD THREE
SERVICES IF YOU PUT ONE IN A
MAINTENANCE YARD OR FLEET
MAINTENANCE YARD.
FULLER MAKE SURE.
NO IS MOSTLY MALE WHICH GREECE
AND POLLUTE FOR MOST PART NARAL
CLEAN PLACE THAT IF THEY DO HAVE
A YOUNG WOMAN.
WORKING THERE WHO HAD A CHILD
THAT.
IT WILL BE MAINTAINED ON UP TO A
STANDARD WHERE.
ARM WHICH IS NOT HEALTHY AT ALL
AND SO ON I DON'T IF ANYTHING I
THINK SHE IS AS CLEAN AND
HEALTHY I DON'T KNOW IF WE NEED.
TO MAKE SURE THAT IT COMES TO A
CERTAIN LEVEL BUT MORE IMPORTANT
OF WORKING WITH THE PEOPLE HAVE
DONE THIS AND I'M SORRY IF YOU
JUST EARLIER TO TALK ABOUT TO
MAKE SURE --
WE CAN ACTUALLY GET THIS DONE
GETTING IS MORE IMPORTANT TO TO
IMPLEMENT IT.
ARM WHICH DEATHLY IMPORTANT I
MAKE THE LAWLER POLICY BUT IS
EQUALLY IMPORTANT TEST TO MAKE
SURE WE CAN IMPLEMENT.
YEAH NO I DIED TOTALLY AGREE
WILL GO BACK TO GO LOOK AT THE
LANGUAGE I MEAN OBVIOUSLY THERE.
THERE COULD BE.
DISPUTES IN AND WE DON'T YOU
KNOW OPPOSED PUREE WE DON'T WANT.
LITIGATION TOOKER AND I I
SUSPECTED THAT IT WON'T HAPPEN
VERY OFTEN.
UNDER THIS BILL BUT WITHOUT THE
PUREE THERE'S VERY LITTLE
INCENTIVE. FOR COMPLIANCE
BECAUSE UNFORTUNATELY ON THE
COMPLAINT SYSTEM AT THE THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER IS NOT --
IT'S NOT A FAST.
ONE AND SO AND ACTUALLY WHEN
WOMEN ARE.
ARE EXPRESSING BREAST MILK IT'S
FOR NOT PERMANENT PERIOD OF TIME
AND SO --
RESOLUTION ON BUT YEAH WILL BOTH
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT TO MAKE SURE
IT'S ON TO MAKE SURE IT'S TIGHT
ENOUGH AND I APPRECIATE THAT THE
OUTFIT AND DIDN'T KNOW ALSO JUST
LOOK AT WHAT WE DID FIRE
DEPARTMENT.
DARN A LOT OF WOMEN WHO
FIREFIGHTERS.
SO.
THE TEMPORARY MAY HAVE MADE MORE
SENSE.
IT ONE STATION BECAUSE THEY ALSO
MOVE FIREFIGHTERS AROUND
PREGNANT SO PUTTING A PERMANENT
ONE IN EVERY.
SO WE WE HAVE TO HAVE THAT.
DISCUSSIONS LIKE HOPEFULLY
THERE'S NOT A FLEXIBILITY.
OKAY THANK YOU.
I GUESS I REMEMBER OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS -- I
WOULD ASK THE QUESTION TO
OPPOSITION YOU I NOTE THAT YOU.
THE CHAMBERS CONCERN IS ABOUT
THE BUILDING CODE IN AUNT AND
HUNCHED RUSSIAN.
PORTIONS HERE --
I DIDN'T HEAR CONCERNS ABOUT.
THE GOLDEN ATTENDED THE BILL I'M
ASSUMING THAT.
THERE ARE NO CONCERNS THERE --
I GUESS TONIGHT* IT YOU KNOW
IT WOULDN'T BE THE TIME TO MAKE
ELECTION ACCOMMODATION IF YOU'RE
MAKING NEW CONSTRUCTION WOULD
THAT BE.
PRECISELY THE TIME --
TO DO SUCH A THING SO WE
UNDERSTAND THAT BUT NO AGAIN AS
I'M ASSEMBLY MEMBER DON'T ARTS
JONES SAWYER STATED NOT EVERY
BUILDING IS THE SAME NOT EVERY
BUILDING IS USED FOR THE SAME
PURPOSE AS A NIGHT I DON'T KNOW
THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY.
BUT I CAN SAY THAT THE CONCERN
IS THE CHOIR MEANT TO PUT THIS
ON EVERY NEW CONSTRUCTION JOB
THAT HAS THESE REQUIREMENTS.
I'M IS GOING TO BE EXTREMELY
COSTLY TO THESE EMPLOYERS WHERE
WERE THE REST OF THE BILL DOES
ALLOW FOR A TEMPORARY STRUCTURE
IF THE NEW CONSTRUCTION IS
OCCURRING THEN YOU HAVE TO PUT
THIS IN WITHOUT THE
CONSIDERATION OF WHETHER OR NOT
THIS IN.
THIS SPACE IS GOING TO BE
UTILIZED.
THANK YOU OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS IN THE DISCUSSION IS
OUR MOTION.
BILL'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
THANK YOU SENATOR WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
OUR THE HYPE APPRECIATE THE OF
EFFORT TO NEED TODAY I ALSO
WANTED TO THANK US AMERICANS OFF
FLETCHER BURGER CO AUTHORSHIP
AND I RESPECT WEST FROM MY BOOK.
THANK YOU THE BILL HAS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION THE SENATOR HAS
ASKED WE MAKE THIS A FIVE FOR
FIVE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE
THURMOND AYE AYE THURMOND AYE
FLORA.
FLOOR NOW GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE JONES
SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE KALRA.
REVERTS.
REVERSE AYE STEINORTH.
STEINORTH NO.
YOUR BILL IS OUT FIVE OR FIVE
CONGRATULATIONS I SEE COLLEAGUES.
BUT AS THE SERGEANTS A CALL ANY
THE AUTHORS TO COME DOWN FOR THE
REMAINING BILLS --
WHILE WE WAIT WE CANNOT TAKE A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
LET ME KNOW ONE BILL THAT WAS
LISTED AS CONSENT IS NO LONGER
ON CONSENT.
A FILE ITEM NINE S. B. FOURTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT HAS BEEN REMOVED
FROM CONSENT AND WILL BE HEARD --
SO ON CONSENT WE HAVE --
FILE ITEM FOR S. B. NINE SEVENTY
ATKINS IS THERE A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
VICE CHAIR MOVES CHAIR SECONDS
UP PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CONSENT CALENDAR IS S. B. NINE
SEVENTY MOTION IS DO PASS
CONSENT TO APPROPRIATIONS.
THURMAN AYE THURMOND AYE FLORA.
FLORA AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE JONES
SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE KALRA REBUTS.
REVERSE AYE STEINORTH STEINORTH
AYE.
IT'S IT IS OUT
.
GRETA THAT WE'RE GONNA LIFT THE
CALL -- FOR
BILLS THAT ARE ON CALL.
S. B. THIRTEEN HUNDRED JACKSON --
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
JUDICIARY ABSENT MEMBERS
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE.
KALRA [inaudible]
RIVAS [inaudible]
WHO'S [inaudible]
NOW.
THE REMAINS ON CALL.
IF IN A COLUMN S. B..
FOURTEEN OH TO LARA'S ABSENT
MEMBERS FLORA. FOURTEEN NO TUVO.
FLORA NOW LEAVE US [inaudible]
STEINORTH [inaudible]
STEINORTH.
S. B. FORTINO TO REMAINS ON CALL.
I'LL IT I'M SORRY THAT BILL IS
OUT SORRY.
S. B. FORTINO TWO IS OUT.
COMMITTEE WELCOME SENATOR
MCGUIRE IS HERE TO PRESENT SP.
FOURTEEN TWENTY EIGHT WELCOME
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY
DOING WELL WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMMENTED
YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN A BUSY DAY
FOR EVERYONE.
I AM.
VERY GRATEFUL TO BE IN A PRISON
S. B..
FOURTEEN TWENTY EIGHT KNOWING
HOW HARD IT IS TO KEEP A JOB --
THIS IS WHY WE'RE ADVANCING THIS
IMPORTANT BILL.
I'M BE NEVER KEEP A JOB IS A
CRITICAL SKILL FOR STUDENTS.
PREPARE FOR ADULTHOOD BUT AS YOU
MAY KNOW.
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES CALIFORNIA
MINER'S TO HAVE WORKED FOR ME IN
ORDER TO SECURE A POSITION.
THESE WORK PERMITS ARE REQUIRED
REGARDLESS OF THE TIME HERE.
EVEN DURING THE SUMMER MONTHS OR
SCHOOL BREAKS.
AND WHILE SCHOOL DISTRICTS MAY
SET THEIR OWN POLICIES ON SCHOOL
PERMITS.
SOME POLICIES REQUIRE STUDENTS
TO HAVE A CERTAIN GRADE POINT
AVERAGE OR ATTENDANCE RATE.
AS A RESULT STUDENTS CAN BE
UNFAIRLY DENIED PARTICIPATION IN
SUMMER WORK.
SUCH AS PROGRAM SPECIFICALLY
INTENDED FOR LOW INCOME IN
DISADVANTAGED YOUTH.
THE CALVARY TRIBAL PAINT A
PARTNERSHIP FOR EXAMPLE WE HAD
THEIR AMAZING.
DECKER DIRECTOR RIGHT NEXT TO ME
OFFER SUBSIDIZE EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR TRIBAL YOUTH.
DURING THE SUMMER MONTHS.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE HAVE BEEN
SEVERAL CASES WHERE STUDENTS ARE
UNABLE TO OBTAIN WORK PERMITS
BECAUSE THEY FEEL THEY FAILED TO
MEET.
THE GPA OR TENANTS REQUIREMENTS
AND THEREFORE HAVE BEEN DENIED
WORK PERMITS IN ORDER TO
PARTICIPATE IN SUMMER PROGRAMS.
FITNESS SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED
FOR THESE IT AMERICAN STUDENTS.
WE MUST HELP ADVANCE STUDENTS
AND DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
ENCOURAGE THOSE WHO WANT TO GAIN
WORK EXPERIENCE.
S. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY EIGHT IS
SIMPLE IT'S GONNA REMOVE THE
BARRIER FOR MINORS TO OBTAIN A
WORK PERMIT.
JUST DURING THE SUMMER MONTHS BY
PROHIBITING THE DENIAL OF A WORK
PERMIT ON THE BASIS OF A
STUDENT'S GRADES.
GRADE POINT AVERAGE OR SCHOOL
ATTENDANCE IF THE STUDENT IS
APPLYING PER WORK PERMIT TO TO
PRINT TO PARTICIPATE NAY GOVERN
ADMINISTERED EMPLOYMENT AND
TRAINING FOR PROGRAM.
SOME EXAMPLES OF THOSE.
THE YOUTH CONSERVATION COURSE OR
LIKE IN THE COUNTY WHERE I LIVE
IN WE HAVE A YOU PSYCHOLOGY
COURSE THROUGH THE CINEMA COUNTY
WATER AGENCY.
CALIFORNIA YOUTH BUILD I IT'S
SUPPORTED BY GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS HERE IN THE CITY
CALIFORNIA.
TRIBAL TEEN OF SUMMER YOUTH
EMPLOYMENT OR YOUTH EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY PROGRAMS OR SERVICES
AND PROGRAMS VERY BY COUNTY MANY
OF US ALREADY HAVE THEM IN OUR
REGION.
S. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY EIGHT IS
AN IMPORTANT BILL THAT WILL HELP
STUDENTS WHO WANT TO IMPROVE
THEMSELVES.
AND LIFT UP THEIR FAMILIES
THROUGH EMPLOYMENT I'VE TO
INCREDIBLE WOMEN HERE TODAY I IN
VERY GRATEFUL FOR THEIR WORK
WE'VE LAURIE LEWIS EDUCATION
DIRECTOR FOR THE TRIP CALVET
TRAVEL TENNIS PARTNERSHIP IN OF
COURSE.
BUT THE MIDDLE AGE AND I JUST
APART FROM LOW BUT DECIDED
ADVOCATE FOR THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY HERE IS WELL
MISTER CHAIR.
WHEN RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AT THE MOST APPROPRIATE
TIME?
THANK YOU POLICE PRESENT TO
WITNESS.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS LAURIE
LEWIS AND I AM WITH CALIFORNIA
TRAVEL TENET THING CURRENTLY OUR
PROGRAM HAS ARE YET PROGRAM
WHERE WE PROVIDE STUDENTS AND
TRANSPORTATION AND WE ALSO
PROVIDE --
FOR THAT TO HAVE --
THAT THERE WERE BATON SORRY I'M
NERVOUS --
BUT WE PROVIDE FOR THEM TO GET
TO WORK BACK TO WORK WE HAVE A
MENTOR WE HAVE OF WELLNESS
COORDINATOR AND EDUCATION
COORDINATOR THAT WORKS WITH THE
STUDENT TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
STAY ACTIVELY ENGAGED ON TRACK
DURING THE SUMMER DURING SCHOOL --
FOR SCHOOL A WE ALSO PROVIDE FOR
THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO HELP
THEM WITH THEIR INTERVIEWING
SKILLS --
ANYTHING THAT THEY WOULD NEED TO
BE EMPLOYABLE --
IT'S A WONDERFUL OPPORTUNITY BUT
OFTEN OUR STUDENTS AVR FUNDED A
LOT OF STUDENTS ARE NOT ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE --
SOMETIMES DUE TO THEIR GPA WE
HAVE STUDENTS WHO WERE NOT
ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN SCHOOL THEY
START OFF AT A THIRTY POINT
THREE YEAR --
THIRTY THREE GPA WE HAVE A
STUDENT GET ALL THE WAY UP TO
ONE POINT NINE AND THE STUDENT
WAS DENIED THE WORK PERMIT
BECAUSE THEY WERE JUST ONE POINT
AWAY.
AND WE HAVE OTHER STUDENTS WHO --
OBVIOUSLY LIVE ON THE
RESERVATION.
CARE THAT THE OLDEST MEMBER OF
THE HOUSEHOLD THEY HAVE TO TAKE
CARE OF FIVE OR SIX OTHER
SIBLINGS WHICH MIGHT ENTITLE
THEM GETTING NO SIBLINGS THE
SCHOOL BECAUSE THEY'RE LIVING
WITH THE GRANDPARENT.
AND THEREFORE THEY ARE MARKED
TRUANT --
EVEN THOUGH THEY ARE STILL
MAINTAINING THEIR GRADES BUT
THEY TOO WERE DENIED FOR THEIR
WORK PERMITS THAT THEY'RE UNABLE
TO ATTEND OUR PROGRAMS.
ARE PROGRAMS WOULD SUPPORT THEM --
AND MAKING SURE THEY HAVE THE
SAME OPPORTUNITIES AS OTHER
STUDENTS WHO DO WHO HAVE THE
THING YOU KNOW SIMILAR
OPPORTUNITIES BUT WITHOUT THE
SAME CHALLENGES.
SO IT IS A WAY FOR US TO TO
EMPOWER OUR STUDENTS BECOME SELF
SUFFICIENT.
SO WE APPRECIATE AND I VOTE IN
THIS MATTER AND WE APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME AND HEARING.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT'S WITNESS IT
MISTER CHAIRMAN PRISON THE
COMMITTEE JUST OF ARTHUR WITH
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY OUT WE'VE THANK GRATEFUL
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY IS DRINK
THAN OUR RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
TRAVEL TEN OF COMMUNITY AND I
WHEN THIS ISSUE CAME TO US THAT
THEIR THEIR YOUTH.
WERE UNABLE --
TO UTILIZES THIS OPPORTUNITIES
IN FRONT OF THEM --
WE START TO LOOK INTO A THE
PROCESS FOR A THE WORK PERMITS
FOR YOUTH.
AND WE CONTACT THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ALL WE FOUND OUT WAS
THAT NOBODY KEEPS TRACK.
OF THE POLICIES THE BUZZ --
SCHOOL DISTRICT BY SCHOOL
DISTRICT WE WANT TO FIND OUT HOW
MANY SCHOOL DISTRICTS MAKE
CONCESSIONS FOR AND WORK WITH
STUDENTS SO THAT THEY CAN GET
ABOVE THE GRADE POINT AVERAGE OR
OR IT WHETHER OR NOT THOSE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAD ACCESS --
TO RESEARCH SHOULD SHOW THAT LOW
INCOME --
STUDENTS WHO DO PARTICIPATE IN A
SUMMER YOUTH EMPLOYMENT TRAINING
PROGRAM ARE MORE LIKELY TO
ACCEPT POVERTY --
AND WOOD WE FOUND A YOU KNOW A
LACK OF OF INFORMATION WHICH WAS
DISHEARTENING --
BUT WHAT WE DO KNOW ABOUT THESE --
FOR WHEN THEY ARE PROGRAMS THAT
ARE BUILT --
TO EMPOWER LOW INCOME YOU OFFER
THEM AT AGE APPROPRIATE --
EMPLOYMENT AND TRAINING AT THE
LIKELIHOOD OF THEM BEING ABLE TO
ACCEPT POVERTY AND IS IS HIGHER
AND ALSO.
THE YOUTH ARE MORE LIKELY TO
MEET SOME OF THE BASIC NEEDS
WHAT WE'VE LEARNED FROM LOW
INCOME YOUTH WHO ARE EMPLOYED AS
AT MANY OF THEM ARE YOU ARE
USING THAT EMPLOYMENT INCOME TO
HELP -- BUOY
AS THE HOUSEHOLDS FOOD INCOME --
SOMETIMES HELP PAY FOR RENT AND
PREVENT EVICTION --
IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT THAT'S A
THAT'S HOW YOUTH HAVE TO SPEND
THEIR MONEY --
BUT IT ALSO THAT CAN KEEP THEM
IN SCHOOL IF THEY'RE NOT
HOMELESS --
AND KEEP THEM FROM SUFFERING AT
THE INDIGNITY OF HUNGER OF THIS
WAS MY OWN EXPERIENCE WITH A
WORK PERMIT AND AND SO I
UNDERSTAND IT WELL --
FOR THESE REASONS WE WE REALLY --
ARE APPRECIATIVE OF THE AUTHOR
FOR INTRODUCING THE BILL IN A
PARTNERSHIP WITH TRAVEL TEN F. --
AND JR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO
ADD ON IN SUPPORT.
SEE NOT IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEN ON TIME TO THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE SOME AND NEVER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER SO I ASKED HER
TO PEOPLE OF CONSENT AND WE HAVE
A HISTORY OF DISCUSSING.
YOUTH WORK PERMITS YOU AND I
MISTER MCGUIRE --
SO I WANTED TO KNOW MORE I A WAS
LOOKED ALARMED --
I I THINK THAT WE HAVE YOUTH
WORK PERMITS FOR A REASON --
WE HAVE A FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
THAT IS A CHANGING THE LAWS
AROUND OR ARE SEEKING TO CHANGE
LAWS AROUND.
AND CHILD LABOR LAWS AND WE HAVE
SOME THE STRONGEST NATION I
APPRECIATE THAT WE WORKED HARD
FOR THAT.
BUT I ALSO UNDERSTAND --
DIFFERENT CIRCUMSTANCES AND
NEEDS FOR CHANGES SO I I WANTED
TO HEAR MORE AND I APPRECIATE
THIS PROGRAM MY CONCERN WITH THE
BILL IS.
HOW BROAD IT IS AND I ASKED MY
STAFF I'D ASK?
YOUR STAFF I THINK FOR EXAMPLES
IN EVEN WHEN YOU SAY YOU FELT IT
KIND OF MADE MY EARS PERK UP
THEY RANDY IS BILL PROGRAM --
AND IT'S A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
SITUATION BECAUSE IT SIXTEEN TO
TWENTY FOUR YEAR OLDS WHO HAVE
NO ATTACHMENT TO A SCHOOL.
SO IT PROBABLY WOULD APPLY IN A
YOUTH BUILD SITUATION BECAUSE OF
THE YOUTH ARE ACTUALLY IN.
GETTING A G. E. D. OR A HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA AT THE SAME TIME
AS THEY'RE IN THIS PROGRAM SO
THAT PROGRAM.
THAT THE WORK PERMIT COMES FROM
THAT SCHOOL.
I THINK A BIGGER CONCERN IS THAT
WE DON'T HAVE STATEWIDE RULES
AROUND IT SO IT THIS IS EITHER.
IN MY OPINION NOT BROAD ENOUGH
BECAUSE IT'S NOT ESTABLISHING
WHAT THAT CRITERIA SHOULD BE --
AND TO ENSURE THAT WERE NOT --
ALLOWING NOT IN THIS SITUATION
BUT IN SOME SITUATIONS YOU CAN
IMAGINE WHERE --
YOUNG PEOPLE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
EMPLOYERS UTILIZE A YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO THE ATTENDANCE THING KIND OF
CAUGHT ME OFF GUARD BECAUSE I
MEAN IF YOUR ATTENDANCE IS BAD
AND AND WHERE ALLOWING YOU TO
WORK AND THEN YOU AFTER
ADDITIONAL --
EXCEPTION FTA TO WORK LONGER AND
MORE HOURS THAN YOU KNOW THAT
YOUR LIMITED EXCEPTION FOR YOUR
LAST BILL THAT WE WE HAD TALKED
ABOUT.
WE'RE CREATING KIND OF A
PATCHWORK OF OF EXCEPTIONS FOR
PERMITS THAT --
WORK PERMITS MEET ME I'M
INCREASINGLY NERVOUS AND SO.
AS I'M I THINK I'M A STAY OFF
THIS TODAY I DON'T THINK IT
MATTERS --
IT'S GOOD APPROPRIATIONS AND
SOME [inaudible]
NOW.
WE MAY NOT BE ABLE TO RESOLVE MY
MY CONCERNS ARE OBVIOUSLY
EVERYTHING THE BOTH OF YOU SAID
I COMPLETELY AGREE WITH I JUST
AM WONDERING KIND OF WHERE WE'RE
GOING WITH THIS.
AND I WOULD BE MUCH MORE
COMFORTABLE EITHER ST FOR THIS
PROGRAM.
THIS IS THE EXCEPTION ON YOU FOR
FOR TRIBAL YOUTH I I'VE BEEN.
YOU KNOW PRETTY COMFORTABLE WITH
THAT I I THINK --
IF WE CREATED A STATEWIDE
STANDARD FOR WHAT OH BY USE WORK
PERMIT LOOKS LIKE I'D BE
COMFORTABLE WITH THAT --
BUT I I'M HAVING A HARD TIME YOU
YOU CREATED VERY.
BROAD BILL IN A SENSE THAT COULD.
CREATE SITUATIONS I THINK THAT
ARE MAKING ME NERVOUS.
NO I I APPRECIATE AND I WANNA
FIRST FAULT THINK THESE IN THE
ONE FOR ALL FOR WORK PARTICULAR
FOR BUTTE IN WORKING FAMILIES
RIGHT THERE IS NO GREATER
CHAMPION.
AND AND THEN I I WILL ALSO SAY
THAT WE WANTED TO BE ABLE TO
LIMIT THIS BILL FROM WHERE WE
WERE IN THE BEGINNING.
SO NUMBER ONE WE'RE NOT CHANGING
ANY DEFINITION OF WHAT A WORK
PERMIT --
WOULD BE AS FAR AS WHAT IS
CURRENTLY BUT CURRENTLY
QUALIFIES HERE IN THE STATE.
YEAH WE DID NEARLY SO NUMBER ONE
I STUDENTS CAN ONLY PARTICIPATE
IN YOUTH WORK PROGRAMS THAT
RECEIVE GOVERNMENT FUNDING.
SO THEY CAN'T GO OUT AND WORK AT
STARBUCKS.
THEY HAVE TO BE A WORK WITH ANY
GOVERNMENT FUNDED --
USE WORK PROGRAM.
BUT WHEN THE QUESTION AT LEAST
YOUR OTHER PROGRAM THAT WE
ALLOWED I'M AN EXCEPTION REPAIRS
THAT'S NOT CONSIDERED A SOMEHOW
BECAUSE THEY HAVE AS SPECIALS
EXEMPTION.
CORRECT IN SO THEY DON'T RECEIVE
GOVERNMENT FUNDING OF HER THAT I
IT'S IT'S AN ADMINISTERED IT'S
OVERSEEN BY THE OFFICE EDUCATION
BUT THEY DON'T RECEIVE ANY
FUNDING ANY GOVERNMENT APPLYING
FOR THAT OKAY.
ON THE SECOND PIECE IS WE ARE
LOOKING AT ALL YOUR LONG WHEN
THIS BILL WAS ORIGINALLY I NIGHT
WE'VE NOW JUST LIMITED TO SUMMER
MONTHS.
AND SO IT'S JUST FOR THIS DE
SUMMER --
MINDS -- IN
AGAIN IT'S JUST ON THE SAME
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
IN PLACE UP FOR YOUTH ACROSS THE
STATE.
BUT AGAIN FOR THIS SPECIFIC BILL
JUST GOVERNMENT FUNDING --
IS WELL IT'S JUST A SUMMER
MONTHS.
YOU I'M SORRY I KNOW WE'RE NOT.
FOURTH KNOW IT'S PLEASE PLEASE
MISTER CHAIR ALLOW ME TO HOUSES
IS THERE IS THIS ANY YEARS WORK
PERMIT.
OF ANY AGE FOR HIGH SCHOOL.
SO THEY HAVE TO BE IN HIGH
SCHOOL I THINK I MISSED THAT SO
THAT WAS.
SO BAD BUT I AS I WOULD BE
FOURTEEN OR FIFTEEN IT COULD BE
IF YOU'RE.
YES IT COULD BE.
SO I WHAT I DO WANT TO FRAME UP
SOMETHING AND THAT IS THAT.
SO.
WE'RE NOT ACTUALLY.
SO WHAT WHAT THE BILL WOULD DO
IS IT WOULD SAY --
YOU STILL HAVE TO GET A WORK
PERMIT.
THE WORK MY PERMIT STILL HAVE TO
MEET ALL OF THE THE RULES --
AND THOSE INCLUDE ALL OF THE
PROTECTIONS FOR YOUTH WORKERS --
BUT BUT YOU CAN'T DENY THAT USE
A SUMMER LA LA A SUMMER MONTHS
[inaudible]
WORK PERMIT. FOR A GOVERNMENT
FUNDED EMPLOYMENT YOUTH
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PROGRAM.
IT IT JUST SOLELY ON THE BASIS
OF THEIR GRADES AND ATTENDANCE
DURING THE SCHOOL YEARS.
IF OUR SCHOOL SCHOOL MONTHS IF
YOU CAN DENY IT BECAUSE THE
PLACE WHERE YOU'VE APPLIED TO
WORK.
DOESN'T MEET THE STANDARDS YEAH --
YOU COULD DO THAT YOU CAN'T DENY
IT SOLELY ON THE FACT THAT THEY
GOT POOR GRADES DURING THE
SCHOOL MONTH AND THEN GIVE THEM
NO OPPORTUNITY IN THE SUMMER
MONTHS --
AND AND THAT'S THAT THE VERY
NARROW PIECE THAT THIS BILL IS
CURRENTLY DOING.
I THINK YOUR QUESTION THOUGH IS
A DOES THAT MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE -- OF A
NOTE BY SAYING GOVERNMENT IS
THAT IS THAT A GOOD ENOUGH
STANDARD --
I THINK WHEN WE TALKED AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE YEAR IN THE
BILL WAS INTRODUCED WITHOUT YES --
BUT TODAY WERE HONORING REFUGEES
AND WERE LOOKING AT WHAT'S
HAPPENING AT OUR BORDER.
IT I'M NOT SURE THAT WE CAN WITH
CONFIDENCE SAY THAT A FEDERAL
WORK PROGRAM UNDER THIS
ADMINISTRATION --
WOULD A PROTECT TO USE I THINK
YOUR QUESTIONS ARE GOOD --
ONE AND IT'S ONE WE DIDN'T AND I
WOULD ADD ONE MORE IN THERE TO
CONSIDER AS WE MOVE FORWARD I AM
REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BUT ON THIS.
NOW SAYING THAT.
I'M NOT SURE WE CAN SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM WITHOUT INCLUDING
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
PROGRAMS RIGHT RIGHT I WOULD
ASSUME THAT THIS IS A FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT PROGRAM YET DID
ABSOLUTELY AS TONIGHT I JUST
WANT TO POINT OUT ONE THING
BECAUSE I AM ACTUALLY THE PERSON
WHO GOES OUT.
AND WORK WITH THE YOUTH.
AND THIS BECAME A VERY BIG
CHALLENGE BECAUSE I SPEND THE
MAJORITY OF MY TIME DURING THIS
TIME OF THE YEAR.
GOING TO SCHOOL DISTRICT AFTER
SCHOOL DISTRICT NOT JUST IN ONE
AREA BUT I SERVICE OF ALL
COUNTIES FROM SAN JOAQUIN TO
MODOC TO DOWN OR AND EVERYTHING
IN BETWEEN.
AND THE CONSTANT CHALLENGES IS
THAT OUR SCHOOLS DO NOT HAVE A
SUMMER PROGRAM FOR OUR STUDENTS
THERE ARE NO SUMMER SCHOOLS
THERE'S NO SUMMER CLASSES
THERE'S NOTHING FOR THE YOU'VE
TO DO.
AND THEN THEY DENIED THE YOUTH A
WORK PERMIT SO I HAVE A I GREW A
GROUP OF YOUTHS WHO WERE AGES.
FOURTEEN TO EIGHTEEN WHO WERE
SITTING IN THE SUMMER WHO ARE
NOW DISCOURAGED BECAUSE THEY
CANNOT WORK THEY'RE NOT DOING
WELL IN SCHOOL THEY CANNOT DO
ANYTHING AND NOW WE'RE FIGHTING
TO KEEP THEM OFF DRUGS TO KEEP
THEM ENGAGED IN TO KEEP THEM
BACK.
SCHOOL SO FOR THAT IT IT'S VERY
PASSIONATE AND EVEN THOUGH WE
ARE TRIBAL COMMUNITY WE WORK
WITH ALL STUDENTS SO WE HAVE
MANY OF YOUTHS WHO COME INTO OUR
PROGRAM WITH FRIENDS AND WE WORK
WITH THEM BECAUSE WE WANT THEM
TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY.
THAT IS I HOPE THAT HELPS THAT
HELP IN AYE LIKE IF AND I'M.
I DON'T THINK I EVER OPPOSE THE
WESTERN CENTER THE WHOLE --
SAID THIS IS TOP I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T FIND
OURSELVES IN A POSITION.
ON THAT WE'VE ALLOWED A LOOPHOLE.
I I WILL SUPPORT THE STATE I
WILL ASK FOR TWO THINGS ONE THAT
THAT WE REVISIT THIS QUESTION ON
ON THE FEDERAL --
I'M PROTECTIONS UNDER FEDERAL
PROGRAMS ON JUST IN CASE THINGS
CHANGE AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL AS
FAR AS PROTECTIONS.
AND THE SECOND BEING I'M I CAN'T.
I'M TRYING I CAN THINK OF AN
EXAMPLE OF A OF A ENTERTAINMENT
WORK PERMIT THAT WOULD FALL
UNDER ONE THESE CATEGORIES BUT
I'D LIKE THEM EXEMPTED FROM THE
SPELL --
BECAUSE THAT.
THE UNIQUE NATURE OF THE
ENTERTAINMENT WORK WITH WORK
PERMIT AND SCHOOLING ON THE SAT
AND AND THE FACT THAT IT'S YEAR
ROUND AND IT'S NOT THAT.
I I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THEIR
THIRD DOESN'T BECOME A LOCAL
STATE OR FEDERAL PROGRAM --
AND YOU HAVE YOU KNOW.
MY DAUGHTER HAD A WORK PERMIT.
SADDAM YOU NOW AND THERE HAD TO
BE A TUTOR ON SAT NIGHT I DON'T
WANT THOSE FEES EXEMPTION
SOMEHOW REPLIED AS THE THAT
YOUNG AND IT'S A TOTALLY
DIFFERENT GROUP OF KIDS RIGHT SO.
THAT WOULD BE MY ONLY REQUEST
TREATMENT MY AND ONE ANIMAL ADDS
THAT IS WILD TRAVEL TEAM IT DOES
RECEIVE FEDERAL FUNDS THERE ARE
STATE STANDARDS.
THAT ADEN STUDENTS HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO ABIDE BY OUT WHEN IT
COMES TO THESE WORK PERMITS AND
SO I THINK THAT THE OTHER REALLY
IMPORTANT PART OF THAT IS.
YES THEY'RE RECEIVING FEDERAL
FUNDING BUT WE ALSO HAVE OUR OWN
STATE STANDARDS AS WELL
[inaudible]
THANK.
SO YOU WILL WORK WITH ME ON
THOSE TWO QUESTIONS THEM FIVE ON
THE ISSUE OF EXAM.
SO.
I MEAN I MIGHT HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH I MEAN I MIGHT LOOK BE
LOOKING FOR SOLUTION WITHOUT A
PROBLEM ON THE ENTERTAINMENT
WORK PERMIT I JUST IT JUST IS A
RED FLAG FOR ME BECAUSE THE
RULES ARE SO DIFFERENT.
AND IT IT IS THE WORK PERMIT THE
GUY.
BY DIFFERENT THAT WE CLASSIFIED
AND AND THE DEFINITIONS HERE BUT
YOU'VE PERMITS --
FOR FOR ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY
THAT THE AGES GO MUCH LOWER SO I
THINK THE ONE JUST BEING HONEST
ABOUT THIS ONE CHALLENGE WE HAD
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY WE LOOKED
AT GOVERNMENT FUNDED AND OR
GOVERNMENT HOSTED WORK PERMIT
PROGRAMS.
I IS BECAUSE IT GOT OUT OF THE
PRIVATE SIDE OF THE MARKET.
I AND IF WE'RE GONNA. ONE
CONCERN I WOULD HAVE IS IF WE'RE
GOING TO EXEMPT ONE INDUSTRY
THEN WE MAY HAVE ON IT OTHER
INDUSTRIES COMING ASK FOR
EXEMPTIONS THAT'S WHY WE TEND TO
LOOK AT THOSE GOVERNMENT FUNDED
GOVERNMENT RUN PROGRAMS --
WHAT I WOULD GET INTO THAT'S I
DON'T WANNA SAY?
ABSOLUTELY EXEMPTION ALL ALL I
WANTED TO DO WAS JUST LOOK AT IT
AND YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT THAT
SCHEDULE ME WITH YOU TO BE AND
TALK MORE ABOUT IT BUT I'M NOT
TRYING TO BE QUIET AND NOW BUT
LET'S.
LET'S BE CLEAR WHAT WE'RE ASKING
EXEMPTION FROM AN EXEMPTION FROM
EXEMPTING THEM FROM SCHOOL.
RIGHT AND IT'S A DIFFERENT
SITUATION MIGHT BE AT UNDER
DIFFERENT WORK PERMIT BUT IT'S
AN INDUSTRY THAT I AND I CAN'T
IMAGINE [inaudible]
I OF FEDERALLY FUNDED PROGRAM
BUT THERE COULD BE ONE
ESPECIALLY NOW ACTUALLY WITH THE
FILM TAX CREDIT I THINK I
REMEMBER THERE WAS DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT CREATING AND PRE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM --
FOR I OUT SEE MEMBERS AND STUFF
I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE NOT --
TAKING AWAY WHAT HAS BEEN BUILT
INTO THE ENTERTAINMENT WORK
PERMITS FOR YOUNG CHILDREN THAT
REQUIRE ON SET TUTORS AND
SCHOOLING AND AND DIFFER ES
DIFFERENT SET OF REQUIREMENTS
BUT I DON'T THINK IT WILL THAT.
IN MAYBE THIS IS SOMETHING WE
GET THROUGH AND YOU CLEAN UP
LANGUAGE ON BECAUSE I THINK THE
FEDERAL.
AND MAKE ENSURING AND I WE DON'T
HAVE TIME TO DO IT WHAT THE
FEDERAL WHAT'S GOOD CHANGES THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS GOING TO
MAKE ON SOME OF THEIR PROGRAMS
AND WHAT PROTECTIONS WE HAVE IN
STATE LAW THAT ARE OUTSIDE OF
THIS THAT WE FEEL COMFORTABLE
THAT THIS.
WE'RE NOT GONNA END UP IN A
SITUATION THAT'S I'M NOT
PROTECTIVE OF CHILDREN IF THE
COMMITTEE THAT AND WILL DO THE
DEEPER DIVE ON THE ENTERTAINMENT
SITE AND I JUST I AM NOT SURE.
IN THIS WOULD ONLY PLAYED IN THE
SUMMER IF THIS BILL WERE TO PASS
IT WOULD ONLY APPLY FOR THE
SUMMER BUT LET'S DO A DEEPER
DIVE NEAR MY COMMITMENT THAT
WILL DO A DEEPER DIVE ON THE
ISSUE.
THAT IS NOT AN INTERFERE ON THAT
CAN THOUGH SPECIALIZED PERMITS
AND ONLY SAY SOMEWHERE JUST
MEANING WHEN PEOPLE ARE NOT
SCHOOL CRACKED NOT NECESSARILY
SOME YOU KNOW YOU ABSOLUTE.
IF YOU'RE A HARD MAN THIS WHEN I
STUDENTS ARE NOT IN SESSION
DURING THE SUMMER RIGHT ABSOLUTE
OR WHATEVER MONTHS.
WHAT IF THIS BILL IS ONLY
APPLYING FOR THE SUMMER MONTHS
WHEN I STUDENTS ARE NOT IN
SCHOOL SUDDENLY PLACE TO
TRADITIONAL SCHOOLS CREEK --
NINETY AROUND FOR PUBLIC IT IS
PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
OKAY.
BUT MY PUBLIC SCHOOLS DON'T HAVE
SUMMER BUT IT YET THERE'S SOME --
IT A I THINK A RIGHT TO KNOW
THAT IN THE LANGUAGE IT
REFERENCES THIS SUMMER MONTHS ON
AND SO WOULD APPLY TO THAT THE
SCHOOLS THAT HAVE THAT --
YEAR ROUND TIME YEAR ROUND
TRACKS SO THE AUTHOR IS OFFERING
TO DO MORE WORK ON THIS SUBJECT
THAT SATISFY YOUR CONCERN --
MEL DO MORE WORK TOGETHER HOUSE
THAT SOMEONE ABSOLUTELY WOULD
HAVE TO BE A CITIZEN TIMELINE I
KNOW YOU'RE BUSY AND AM BUT SHE
JUST IN TIME ON THIS ISSUE SO
WHAT THE TO CLEAR FINE PIECES IS
THAT --
SEVERAL MONTHS.
BUT IN THE ISSUE OF THE
ENTERTAINMENT EXCELLENT HOPE
WITHOUT SATISFIES THE MEMBERS --
CONCERN AND LEAVE THAT THERE'S A
MOTION.
THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED ANY OTHER DISCUSSION.
SEE NOW WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE.
WOULD RESPECT ASKING I DON'T
THINK YOU FOR ALLOWING THE
DISCUSSION THINK EVEN DISCUSSION
TODAY SPORADIC YOU PASS
RECOMMENDATION WE JUST CALL THE
ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR THURMOND AYE AYE
THURMOND AYE FLORA.
FLORA AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
CONSULT WITH YOUR EYES JONES
SAWYER KALRA.
ROBUST.
THE BUS AYE STEINORTH AYE
STEINORTH AYE [inaudible]
IF YOU.
THANK YOU THAT BILL IS OUT
CONGRATULATIONS WE'RE GOING.
TO SHORTLY BE TAKING S. B. NINE
THIRTEEN HERTZBERG BUT WE'RE
GOING TO QUICKLY --
HAVE US A MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
PRESENT AG OUR THIRTY FOUR THIS
BILL HAS SUPPORT --
ON BOTH SIDES AND WE CAN TAKE
THAT BILL NOW SO WE CAN HEAR
FROM SENATOR HERTZBERG AND HIS
WITNESS [inaudible]
YIELDING.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA'S
YIELDING TO SENATOR --
HERTZBERG THANK YOU SIR --
PLEASE COME FORWARD WITH THIS OF
THEIR PLAN SIGN SO SORRY TAKING
WE'RE WE'RE HAPPY TO ACCOMMODATE.
THAT MAKE YOU ASKED WE ARE READY
WHENEVER YOU ARE READY.
THIS THIS MEASURE CAME IT'S IT
CAME OF THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
THROUGH THE LA BEAUTIFICATION
PROJECT BASICALLY THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES HAS.
A WHOLE HOST OF THROUGH
ORDINARILY HARD WORKING ON CODE
COMMUNITY GROUPS THAT ARE
EXCELLENT AND GRAFFITI ABATEMENT
AND SO THEY'VE REACHED IT YET
AND THE DEPARTMENT
INDUSTRIALIZATION IS BASICALLY
SAID THAT THEY PROVIDE THAT
THEIR PREVAILING WAGE IN WHAT
WE'VE DONE HERE IN THIS.
A A MEASURE TOGETHER WITH OUR
LABOR IS TO CRAFTING THEIR
EXEMPTION WHERE THEY'RE THESE
PRE APPRENTICE PROGRAM SO THE
NOTION IS THESE KIDS ARE COMMON
IN.
AND NOT ONLY ARE THEY MAKING
SOME MONEY BUT WE'RE ALSO GIVING
THEM A PATH --
TOWARD PREPAREDNESS TO BECOMING
PAINTERS WORKING WITH THE
PAINTERS UNIONS THE BUILDING
TRADES WITNESSES ARE HERE.
IT'S REALLY I THINK GIVEN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES A PRETTY ELEGANT
SOLUTION OF MARRYING COMMUNITY
PATH FORWARD FOR KIDS AND GIVING
THEM AN OPPORTUNITY.
AND REALLY COOL COMMUNITY GROUPS
THAT TURN OVER THE WITNESSES.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THANK YOU MY
NAME IS JOE SAINT JOHN I'M WITH
THE COMPUTER CREATE TOWN YOUTH
AND COMMUNITY CENTER.
AND WE'RE FORMED OVER FORTY
YEARS AGO NOT AS A PAINTING
CONTRACTOR WE REFORM DOES A
ORGANIZATION THAT PROVIDES
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES TO
KOREATOWN.
AND WHAT THIS BILL WILL ALLOW US
TO DO IS TO CONTINUE PROVIDING
THE SERVICES THAT WE'VE DONE
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE IN
GRAFFITI REMOVAL.
WHILE ALLOWING --
WHILE GIVING US AN OPTION TO BE
ABLE TO COMMUNITY MEMBERS INTO
PRE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM SO
THEY CAN JOIN THE TRADES AND THE
GREAT PAYING JOBS THAT ARE THERE
SO WE ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS MOTION IN.
THE TRADES TO HELP US SOME GET
TO THIS PLACE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND GOOD AFTERNOON MONIES OKAY
LA FLORES --
THE DIRECTOR OF NORTHEAST
GRAFFITI BUSTERS --
HERE TO SUPPORT SENATE BILL.
NINE THIRTEEN OUR PROGRAM HAS
BEEN REMOVING GRAFFITI SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND ONE IF THIS BILL --
DOES NOT PASS WE WOULD BE FORCED
TO PAY THE PREVAILING WAGE WHICH
ARE PROGRAM CANNOT AFFORD --
BECAUSE IT WAS TOO FAR FOR CREWS
AND THE PROGRAM WOULD SUFFER FOR
IT -- WITH
THE COLLABORATION OF THE OF THE
TREES WE WOULD DIALECTIC
CONTINUE OUR WORK WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH THE
TRAITS --
AND WITH YOUR PERMISSION PROGRAM --
THIS PROGRAM WOULD PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR I MANY
RESIDENTS ARE COMMUNITIES AND
ELECTED THANK US IN OUR
HERTZBERG FOR ALL HIS LEADERSHIP
ON THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY THE
VICE CHAIR ALL SECOND IT'S
SUPPORT SUPPORT IF THE WITNESS
NEEDS.
TO MAKE IT TO A FLIGHT WE
CONCERN EXCUSE THE WITNESSES --
ó.
BUT IT IS SUPPORT D'AMATO
EDUCATION WE WANT TO HEAR FROM
YOU BUT IF ANYONE NEEDS TO RUN
NOW OF ITS SUPPORT SUPPORT AND
IT HAS A MOTION AND A SECOND --
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS HAS IDEAS
ON HALF THE STATE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES
MISS WHATEVER THE MEMBERS ANDREW
AND WE WERE THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES WE SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MY QUEST REPRESENTING A DISTRICT
COUNCIL SIXTEEN PAINTERS AND
ALLIED TRADES IN SOLIDARITY WITH
MY COLLEAGUES IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
PETER'S KNOWLEDGE RIGHT THANK
YOU OR ANYONE ELSE WAS AN ADD ON
AND SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
THERE'S OPPOSITION PLEASE COME
FORWARD [inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
I SEEM NINE OF QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SOME REMEMBER REVAMPS.
UMNO THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR
HERTZBERG --
FOR FOR THE SPELL --
AT AS YOU MAY KNOW I WAS A
PUBLIC WORKS COMMISSIONER IN THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES --
A FEW MONTHS AGO.
PRIOR TO BEING ELECTED --
AND WORK DIRECTLY WITH --
THE CONTRACTORS HERE AND I I A
WITNESS ON HOW GREAT THE WORK
THAT -- YOU
DO FOR OUR COMMUNITIES
ESPECIALLY IN MY DISTRICT I'M
AND I PARTICULARLY LIKE THE THE
PRE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM THAT
IS PART OF THIS BILL.
ON SO THANKS TO THE BUILDING
TRADES ON FOR YOUR SUPPORT --
AND VERY EXCITED --
YOU KNOW I HAVE I REMEMBERED.
YOU ABOUT A YEAR AGO I'M RELATED
TO THIS ISSUE AND I'M VERY HAPPY
TO NOW BE ON THIS AND IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL TO THANK YOU.
THANKYOU SO IN THE VERY BEST
ANYONE ELSE ANY OTHER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS --
SEEING NONE --
WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSELY KNOWN ANY
CLOTHES THAT WOULD CERTAINLY
ENJOY YOU KNOW THIS BILL QUITE
FRANKLY CAME FROM INSPIRATION.
IN THE NORTHEAST VALLEY FROM
SCOTT ANGEL CITY COUNCIL MEMBER
MARIA MARTINEZ AND I THINK
PUBLIC WORKS COMMISSIONER BEFORE
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER --
MONICA --
RODRIGUEZ AND I SHOULD LIKE TO
CONSULT WITH YOUR OFFICE TO JOIN
IN AS A REGULAR CO AUTHOR
PRINCIPLE KALRA JOINT AUTHORED
WHATEVER BECAUSE THIS IS ALL
PART OF OUR COMMUNITY THAT WAS
CARRYING THIS BECAUSE WE LOST
OUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND NOW WE
HAVE GOT THIS FANCY NANCY MIT
SUPER.
SMART.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHO'S I'M SO
EXCITED TO WORK WITH SO I'D LOVE
TO BRING INTO THIS PROCESS
ALONG THE WAY I THINK IT WOULD
BE GREAT.
THANK YOU THAT'S WHEN I VOTE.
THE BILL HAS TO DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR THURMAN AYE
THURMOND AYE FLORA.
FLORA I CONSULTANT RICHARD JONES
SAWYER [inaudible]
JOHN.
YEAH DIPLOMA SAWYER.
AYE [inaudible]
KALRA.
KALRA AYE GRIEVANCE.
REVERSE AYE STEINORTH.
BUT DOES OUT CONGRATULATIONS AND
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU HAS A TRAVEL.
SO REMEMBER GARCIA.
AZ OUR THIRTY FOUR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND COLLEAGUES.
AND MARK DELIGHTED TO BE BEFORE
YOU TO INTRODUCE AG OUR THIRTY
FOUR LABOR SHORTAGES IN
AGRICULTURE.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AS
YOU ALL KNOW THE INDUSTRY
EMPLOYS MORE THAN EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND FARMWORKERS ACCORDING
TO THE TWO DOWN SIXTEEN UC DAVIS.
SAID HE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
APPOINTMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT.
AT THE FOOD AND AG DEPARTMENT
ESTIMATES TO CALIFORNIA'S
AGRICULTURE OUTPUT INCLUDES MORE
THAN FOREIGNER COMMODITIES
INCLUDING.
OVER ONE THIRD OF THE COUNTRY'S
VEGETABLES AND TWO THIRDS OF THE
COUNTRY'S FOODS [inaudible]
AND NOTS ACCORDING TO THE
NATIONAL ARE QUICK TO SURVEY
OVER 6% OF FARMWORKERS ARE
UNAUTHORIZED AND VARIOUS SOURCES
ESTIMATE THAT THE NUMBER.
OF UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS MAKE
SEAT. TO CLOSE 275%.
IF THOSE UNAUTHORISED WORKERS
WERE TO BE DEPORTED --
AND WHAT WE'VE SEEN IS SOME
PROGRESSIVE AS IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT DIE IN THESE
PARTICULAR INDUSTRIES AS OF
RECENT.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THEY WOULD
BE A MAJOR A NATIONAL FOOD
SHORTAGE SECURITY PROBLEM.
BEFORE AS WELL I BELIEVE THAT
STATE HAVE THE RIGHT TO ADDRESS
THEIR OWN LABOR ISSUES THE US
CONSTITUTION.
MAKES IT EXPLICITLY CLEAR THAT
IMMIGRATION ISSUES ARE UNDER THE
JURISDICTION OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
TODAY'S FARMWORKERS ARE AGING
AND THEIR CHILDREN.
I DO NOT WANT TO WORK IN THE
FIELDS AND MEANWHILE THERE ARE
FEWER IMMIGRANTS COMING TO THE
COUNTRY TO REPLACE THEM.
THIS RESOLUTION WOULD PUT THE
ISSUE OF LABOR SHORTAGES ON THE
RADAR THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
AND WOULD URGE CONGRESS TO ALLOW
STATES TO ADDRESS THEIR OWN
LABOR ISSUES --
AGAIN I WANT TO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND YOU'RE A TEAM --
FOR ALLOWING US TO COME BEFORE
YOU BRING THIS ISSUE FORWARD
CONTINUE --
WHAT I STARTED OFF AS IT APART
CONVERSATION SEVERAL MONTHS AGO
REGARDING THE SUBJECTS OF --
WE HAVE ONE WITNESS AYE THAT
WILL BE SPEAKING.
THANK YOU PLEASE PROCEED MEMBERS
I'M ARNOLD ATORES I'M
REPRESENTING CLINIC AS INVITED
SALINAS AND MONTEREY COUNTY.
WHEN WE PREPARED A THIS EFFORT?
IT WAS -- TO
SUPPORT --
AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE WHICH
YOU HEARD. TO TO VOTE ON THE
REALITY IS THAT THE DISCUSSIONS
IN CONGRESS TODAY ARE EITHER
AROUND CHILDREN OR AROUND DHAKA.
BOTH POPULATIONS DESERVE A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF DISCUSSION
AND RESOLUTION TO THE SPECIFIC.
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT CONFRONT THEM
BUT WHAT WE CONTINUE TO IGNORE
THE PARENT GENERATION.
WE TRY TO PUT THIS RESOLUTION IN
THE CONTEXT OF AN ECONOMIC
REALITY AND THAT IS THAT THE
AMERICAN BORN WORKERS REGARDLESS
OF THEIR ETHNICITY IN THE RACE.
DO NOT WANT TO WORK IN THE
FIELDS OF STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S REGARDLESS OF THE
INCREASE IN WAGES --
THERE ARE A CLEAR --
CROPS THAT ARE INCREASING THEIR
WAGES TO TRY TO ATTRACT AMERICAN
BORN WORKERS.
THAT'S SIMPLY NOT TAKING PLACE
IN THE HEARING THAT YOU HAD ON
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE YOU HAD.
A REPRESENTATIVE OF ONE OF THE
ORGANIZATION'S OPPOSED TO THE
BILL INDICATING THAT THERE WERE
EIGHT HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE AND THE
UNEMPLOYMENT OF ROLES OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ARE UNFORTUNATELY NOT OF THOSE
EIGHT HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND
ARE INTERESTED IN COMING OUT TO
WORK IN THE FIELDS.
AND NOW THERE IS AN ARGUMENT
THAT SAYS YOU COULD PAY FIFTY
DOLLARS AN HOUR AND THEY WOULD
COME OUT TO WORK.
AVOCADOS PAY TWENTY DOLLARS AN
HOUR --
GRAPES ARE PAYING UP TO
SEVENTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR AND
THESE ARE GOOD WAGES --
AND MANY OF THEM ARE NOW
CARRYING --
SO I THINK IT'S VERY VERY
IMPORTANT THAT THIS COMMITTEE
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
INJECTING.
A VERY IMPORTANT --
NARRATIVE THAT IS BEING LOST IN
THE DEBATE IN CONGRESS AND THAT
IS WHAT HAPPENS TO THE PARENTS.
THE PARENTS WHO ARE WORKING THE
PARENTS WHO ARE MAKING
CONTRIBUTIONS --
WHO IN MOST CASES IN THIS
POPULATION OF FARM WORKERS HAVE
BEEN HERE BETWEEN TEN AND
SEVENTEEN YEARS IN THE UNITED
STATES AND IN CALIFORNIA WORKING?
SO UNFORTUNATELY THE ELEMENTS IN
THE INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE IN
CONGRESS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DELEGATION --
ARE TRUE IN WHAT THEY CAN IT
APPEARS THAT FROM ALL MIT MEDIA
COVERAGE BUT THE REALITY IS THAT
THEY'RE EXCLUDING.
A VERY VERY IMPORTANT ECONOMIC --
REALITY OF CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY
WHICH IS AGRICULTURE AND THEY IN
THE PROCESS ARE IGNORING THE
POPULATION THAT MAKE THAT
ECONOMY.
OUR THAT ECONOMIC SECTOR
CALIFORNIA AS EFFECTIVE AND IS
PRODUCTIVE AND IMPORTANT AS IT
IS SO.
WE HOPE THAT --
YOU WILL BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THIS
IN THAT --
GIVES US A CHANCE TO MOVE THIS
TO CERTAIN MEMBERS IN THE
LECTURE IN THE CONGRESS --
TO HAVE THEM UNDERSTAND THE
CALIFORNIA IS LOOKING --
FOR A PARTNERSHIP --
OF SORTS TO WORK WITH THEIR
DELEGATION IN THE HOUSE AND THE
SENATE TO TRY AND ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE -- IN
A WAY THAT DOESN'T CREATE A
CRISES IN A WAY THAT AVOIDS WHAT
WE SEE TAKING PLACE TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU OTHERS WISHING TO ADD
ON IN SUPPORT I'VE SEEN NINE IS
THERE ANY OPPOSITION --
SAY NONE TO THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
I SEEN NONE IS THERE A MOTION.
SMOOVE THE SECOND IT IS HAS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION SERVICE LIKE
TO CLOSE THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
US TO PRESENT A SIDE RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU AT BEST TRAVEL AS YOU
PASS RECOMMENDATION PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
MOTION IS BE ADOPTED TO THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR THURMOND AYE AYE
THURMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA NOT VOTING GONZALEZ
FLETCHER JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE KALRA.
KALRA I REQUEST.
ME LESS AYE STEINORTH.
THAT SOLUTION IS OUT THANK YOU
THANK YOUR MATCH CONGRATULATIONS
AYE BECAUSE SENATOR PAN PRESENT.
SP.
TWELVE FIFTY TWO SENATORS CHAIR
MEMBERS PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU
READY OKAY.
SO I'M HERE TO PRESENT SP TWELVE
FIFTY TO A SIMPLE BUT IMPORTANT
BILL THINK THEY'RE AWESOME READY
THESE BILLS --
CIVIL IMPORTANT ALTHOUGH I'M
SURE THAT ALL WORKERS HAVE TO
BELIEVE ACCESS THEIR PAYMENT
INFORMATION AND RECORDS.
SINCE THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES
CALIFORNIA'S AFFORDED WORKERS
THE IMPORTANT RIGHT FEEL
INSPECTOR COPY PAYMENT RECORDS
KEPT BY THE EMPLOYERS.
HOWEVER IT HAS BEEN REPORTED
THAT SOME OF PLAYERS IN THE
AGRICULTURAL FIELD ARE
SELECTIVELY READING THE CURRENT
LAW THE FORCE EMPLOYEES.
PROVIDER OWN MEANS OF COPYING
RECORDS.
THIS IS OF COURSE NOT ONLY A
PRACTICAL AND REASONABLE BUT
ALSO CONTRADICTS THE SPIRIT AND
INTENT OF THE LAW.
BUT MAKING A SLIGHT CHANGE
EXISTING LAW THE GIVE WORKERS
THE RIGHTS TO INSPECT OR RECEIVE
A COPY OF PAYMENT RECORDS LET'S
CIVIC AMBER.
FOR PREVENTS SIMILAR HARMFUL
ACTIONS FROM OCCURRING IN THE
FUTURE THIS BILL SPUR US
SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA REAL.
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION SUPPORT BY UNITED
FARM WORKERS TO CALIFORNIA CLINT
LAWYERS ASSOCIATION AND EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES --
SP TWELVE FIFTY TWOS NO FORMAL
OPPOSITION AND DIVES LIKE WE ASK
WHAT I'VE IT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MARK
CHOCOLATE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AS SENATOR
SENATE SPONSOR OF THE BILL THIS
IS A NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
STATUTE.
THAT WAS ENACTED BEFORE
SMARTPHONES BEFORE SCANNERS
BEFORE PORTABLE COPY MACHINES.
THE YOU THE TERM OF ART AT THE
TIME WAS.
INSPECT OR COPY YOUR PAY STUBS
VIRTUALLY EVERY EMPLOYER IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA INTERPRETS
THAT LANGUAGE TO MEAN.
PROVIDE THE WORKER A COPY OF
THEIR PAY STUBS UPON THEIR
REASONABLE REQUEST. FOR THIRTY
YEARS THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
EMPLOYERS MOSTLY EMPLOYERS WHO
ARE ENGAGED IN WAGE THEFT WHO
ARE TRYING TO STOP PROSECUTION
OF THESE CASES BY IMPOSING
BARRIERS TO THEIR TO TO THE
RECEIPT OF WAGE STUB INFORMATION
WHICH ARE VITAL TO WAGE THEFT
CASES.
AND THEY'RE THE REASON FOR THIS
STATUTE MOST RECENTLY AS I'VE
LEARNED THAT ONE OF OUR OFFICES
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
HAD STOP CONTESTING EMPLOYER
DENIALS OF THE RIGHT TO RECEIVE
A COPY OF THEIR CLIENTS WAGE
STUBS.
AND WERE ED PURCHASED A SCANNER
AND A LAPTOP FOR THE SOLE
PURPOSE OF GOING TO THE
EMPLOYERS OFFICE TO MAKE THE
COPIES THEMSELVES.
I'M AS THE SENATOR SAID THIS IT
CONFLICTS WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
HISTORY OF THE ACT.
AND IT'S ANACHRONISTIC LANGUAGE
THAT CAN BE RECTIFIED BY SIMPLY
CHANGING THIRD WORD.
COPY TO RECEIVE A COPY AND
THAT'S ALL THE BILL DOESN'T
WOULD ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHERS WISHING TO ADD
ON IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
THAT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO
ADD ON IN SUPPORT.
AND THE OPPOSITION.
A SCENE NONE WILL TURN TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
BILL'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
IT HAS TO PASS RECOMMENDATION
WOULD LIKE CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I PUT THANK YOU.
Q. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS THURMOND TIE
THURMOND AYE FLORA.
FLORA NOT VOTING.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER JONES SAWYER
JONES SAWYER AYE KALRA.
KALRA I REQUEST BECAUSE I
STEINORTH.
YOU BILLS UP CONGRATULATIONS
THANK YOU THANKS SO MUCH.
A SENATOR GALGIANI IS OUR
REMAINING GO --
PRESENTING SP TWELVE TWENTY
THREE IS THERE SOMEONE FROM
SENATOR GALGIANI OFFICE HERE
[inaudible]
WE LET'S SAID LIFT A CALL ON
BILLS THAT ARE ON CALL PLEASE.
S. B. THIRTEEN HUNDRED A MOTION
IS DO PASSED TO DO JUST VERY
COMMITTEE.
A ABSENT MEMBERS KALRA.
KALRA AYE REBUS [inaudible]
REVERSE I THAT THOSE OUT.
S. B. NINE THIRTY SEVEN KALRA
[inaudible]
KALRA AYE.
S. B..
NINE SEVENTY THE CONSENT
CALENDAR KALRA.
KALRA AYE.
S. B. TWELVE EIGHTY FOUR JACKSON --
UPS MEMBER REBUS.
REVERSED BY.
S. B. FOURTEEN OH TO SENATOR
LARA --
REVERSE.
THE US I S. B. --
FOURTEEN TWENTY EIGHT ABSENT
MEMBERS JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE KALRA
[inaudible]
KALRA AYE
AND I'M NOT [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible] ONE YEAH RIGHT.
HR THIRTY FOUR HUG GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER NOT VOTING.
S. B. [inaudible]
NINE THIRTEEN GONZALEZ FLETCHER
[inaudible]
HERTZBERG AYE.
CONSULT WITH YOUR AYE.
S. B. TWELVE FIFTY TWO PAN
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
CONSULT WATCHER I STEINORTH
[inaudible]
SO.
AND S. B.. TWELVE FIFTY TWO PAN.
ARABS NOT.
NOT VOTING STEINORTH NOT VOTING.
HR.
THIRTY FOUR STEINORTH NOT VOTING.
S. B. NINE THIRTEEN HERTZBERG
STEINORTH AYE [inaudible] THREE
COMMITTEE WELCOMES SENATOR
GALGIANI WHO IS HERE TO PRESENT
S. B. TWELVE TWENTY THREE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE WE KNOW
YOU MADE MANY ATTEMPTS TO
PRESENT THIS TODAY.
PROBLEMATIC SHARON MEMBERS BUSY
DAY FOR YOU AS WELL I KNOW --
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT SP TWELVE TWENTY THREE
WHICH WILL REQUIRE THE DIVISION
OF LABOR STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT
TO DEVELOP RECOMMENDATIONS TO
THE LEGISLATURE. FOR INDUSTRY
SPECIFIC HARASSMENT AND
DISCRIMINATION PREVENTION POLICY.
FOR USE BY EMPLOYERS IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY.
RECENT REVELATIONS UNDERSCORE
THE EXTENT TO WHICH WIDESPREAD
SEXUAL HARASSMENT EXIST WITHIN
VIRTUALLY EVERY INDUSTRY.
THESE INCIDENTS UNDERMINE THE
ACHIEVEMENTS OUR STATE IS MADE
TOWARDS GENDER EQUITY IN THE
WORKPLACE.
HIGHLY SKILLED AND TRAINED WOMEN
OF THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY
CONTRIBUTE GREATLY TO
CALIFORNIA'S INFRASTRUCTURE AND
ECONOMY.
HOWEVER DESPITE EFFORTS TO
RECRUIT WOMEN IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY WOMEN MAKE
UP JUST 3% OF CALIFORNIA'S TOLD
CONSTRUCTION WORK FORCE.
AND ONLY TWO POINT 4% OF THE
APPRENTICES AB ENROLLED IN THE
M. PRETENTIOUS.
SYSTEM.
S. B. TWELVE TWENTY THREE
ADDRESSES THIS PROBLEM BY STOP
WISHING ADVISORY COMMITTEE TO
DEVELOP AN INDUSTRY SPECIFIC
ANTI HARASSMENT AND
DISCRIMINATION POLICY IN
TRAINING STANDARD. FOR USE BY
CONSTRUCTION EMPLOYEE.
EFFORTS TO PROMOTE RECRUITMENT
AND RETENTION OF BOTH FEMALE
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS CAN
ACTIVELY ALLEVIATE BOTH OF THESE
PROBLEMS.
I'LL BE TAKING CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS IN THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS RAISED IN THE ANALYSIS
THE BILL SPONSORED BY THE
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES.
WERE HERE WITH ME TODAY TO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
YOU THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
ME I'D VOTE.
THANK YOU BILL HAS A MOTION AND
A SECOND CHAIR SECONDS PLEASE
PROCEED.
SIR MR MY RECESS IDEAS ON BEHALF
OF STATE BUILDING CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL --
WENT THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
VERY THOROUGH ANALYSIS THANK THE
SENATOR FOR CARRYING THIS
IMPORTANT BILL IT'S A COMPANION
BILL WITH ANNA.
ASSEMBLY BILL CARRIED BY
ASSEMBLY WOMAN COUNTY YOU KNOW
TO TRY TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES AT
THE ACTUAL CONSTRUCTION SITE
WE'VE DONE A LOT OF GREAT WORK
OF TRYING TO RECRUIT MORE PEOPLE
FROM THE COMMUNITY SPECIFICALLY
TARGETING MORE WOMEN INTO OUR
INDUSTRY.
AYE SHE STATED THE NUMBERS ARE
VERY DISMAL WE HAVE TRIED AND
WE'RE DOING OUR BEST TO HAVE
THEM ACTUALLY GET INTO THE
PRESSURE PROGRAM BUT ALSO STAY
IN THE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM.
WE HAVE A SIGNIFICANT HIGH DROP
OUT RATE WITHIN THIS FOR SIX
MONTHS.
WE'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS THAT
ISSUE SO THAT WHEN A WOMAN GOES
INTO THE CONSTRUCTION SITE SHE
SEES MORE FEMALES IN THE
CONSTRUCTION AYE WORKING
ALONGSIDE WITH HER WE BELIEVE
THAT THESE TWO COMPANION BILLS
WILL CHANGE THE CULTURE OF THE
JOB SITE.
AND WILL HOW FOURTEEN MORE WOMEN
INTO THE CONSTRUCTION AND THE
STREETS ARE IMPORTANT FOR THOSE
REASONS WE STRONGLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE --
IS JESSICA STENDER SENIOR
COUNSEL FOR WORKPLACE JUSTICE
AND PUBLIC POLICY EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES OUT WE REGULARLY WORK
WITH WOMEN IN THE TRADES WE KNOW
THAT -- THE
VAST MAJORITY OF MINIMUM WAGE
AND LOW WAGE WORKERS ARE WOMEN --
AND THE COMPARISON BETWEEN WHAT
YOU MAKE IT A MINIMUM WAGE JOB
AND A JOB LIKE THE TRADES A
SUBSTANTIAL AN AVERAGE JOURNEY
WORKER CAN EARN ABOUT THIRTY
DOLLARS AN HOUR IN SPECIALIZED
ROLLS UP.
TO SIXTY SO THAT DIFFERENCE OF
COURSE MAKES IT MEANS THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN MAKING A REAL
LIVING FOR YOURSELF AND YOUR
FAMILY. ONE OF THE BIGGEST
OBSTACLES WE'VE SEEN WOMEN FACE
I'VE HEARD THERE'S VERY SEVERELY
UNDER REPRESENTED ABOUT 3% BOTH
NATIONALLY AND IN CALIFORNIA AND
ONE OF THE BIGGEST BARRIERS THAT
WE SEE TWO WOMEN STAYING IN
THESE JOBS.
IS THE HARASSMENT THAT THEY
FREQUENTLY FACE THERE OFTEN THE
ONLY WOMAN OR ONE OF A FEW WOMEN
ON THIS JOB SITE.
ALMONDS OF HAVING THIS KIND OF
TRAINING THAT'S NOT ONLY
TRAINING BUT THE INDUSTRY
SPECIFIC TRAINING IS REALLY
CRITICAL SO THAT PEOPLE GET AT
THE REAL ROOT CAUSES OF
HARASSMENT AND WHAT CAN BE DONE
IN THE SPECIFIC JOB SITES TO
ADDRESS IT.
SO WE STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT
ON THIS BILL AND ROGER AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
I THINK YOU OTHERS WISH NAT ON
IN SUPPORT.
MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MIKE WEST REPRESENTING
THE WOMEN AND MEN OF DISTRICT
COUNCIL SIXTEEN PAINTERS AND
ALLIED TRADES AND ESPECIALLY.
MEDICINE HOLE WHO'S THE
POLITICAL DIRECTOR FOR PAINTERS
ANDALLIED TRADES WAS MY PREMISE
IN THE FIELD AND SUCCEEDED ME AS
POLITICAL DIRECTOR FOR DISTRICT
COUNCILS SIXTEEN IN STRONG
SUPPORT [inaudible]
Q..
LIKE WE KNOW WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE ADDING ON IN SUPPORT.
I IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WE TRIED TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS --
SEEING NONE THE BILL HAS A
SECOND --
MOTION AND A SECOND WOULD YOU
LIKE THE CLOTHES THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IPHONE
THANK YOU SENATE THIS BILL LET'S
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE THURMAN
AYE AYE THURMOND AYE FLORA.
FLORA AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER AYE KALRA.
KALRA I REQUEST.
THE BUS I STEINORTH STEINORTH
AYE.
SEE AN ILLICIT BILLS OUT THANK
YOU [inaudible]
A GAS.
BRING THIS CONCLUDES --
ARE HEARING THAT WE ARE CHEN